Es ist sicherlich ein Wichtiger, doch es ist so interessant, so zahlreiche, so mindverstehend, dass es nahe die.
Dieses Welt ist nicht komplett.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 173. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute geht es mal wieder darum, ein Thema nachzuholen, was ich unbedingt mal machen musste, damit endlich die E-Mails stoppen, die mir das am laufenden Meter vorschlagen, dass ich das doch unbedingt mal tun müsste. Sie sehen davon, dass ich sowieso erschlagen bin mit Themenvorschlägen, aber davon möchte ich euch gar nicht abhalten, das zu machen. Ich arbeite das lieber ab. Und im Mittelpunkt der Sendung heute stehen die Pen & Paper-Rollenspiele, wie man so schön sagt. Die ganze Spielerei hat jetzt hier schon langsam ein bisschen Traditionen. Hausradio Express und R62 hat sich ja schon so mit Brettspielen auseinandergesetzt. Da ging das schon mal so ein bisschen in diese Richtung, einerseits mal vorzustellen, was denn eigentlich so kulturell in so einer Szene überhaupt zu holen ist, beziehungsweise was man sich mit dem Begriff dann letzten Endes auch wirklich konkret vorstellt. Naja, und das ist bei diesem Thema glaube ich auch nötig. Und da ich ja keine Ahnung habe, dachte ich mir, reden wir mal darüber mit Leuten, die das ein bisschen betreiben und ich begrüße. Da muss ich jetzt erstmal nochmal nachschlagen hier, das komplizierteste Namensduo, was CAI bisher aufzubieten hat. Niels Kobschätzki, hallo und Sören Pusbatzkies.
Hey und hallo.
Habe ich es richtig ausgesprochen?
Nein, das macht aber nichts.
Pusbatzkies.
Richtig, jetzt klappt es.
Oh man, das ist immer... Nächstes Mal will ich eine andere Freundgröße.
Aber wir sind halt einfach die Skandinaven, Niels und Sören, das funktioniert schon.
Ah, stimmt.
Ja. Das lässt ja tief blicken.
Da sehe ich ja gleich so Wikinger von meinem geistigen Auge.
Oh, bitte nicht.
Nein. Naja, aber das hat ja auch schon so ein bisschen so einen mystischen Charakter, so irgendwie das ganze Nordische. Also ihr seid Rollenspieler, um es mal gleich vorweg zu nehmen, beziehungsweise ihr kennt euch da ein bisschen aus. Wie seid ihr denn da überhaupt zu gekommen?
Oh, ich kann sagen, der Niels ist schuld.
Niels ist schuld, na fangen wir mal an.
Ja, also ich hab einen großen Bruder und der hat irgendwie angefangen mit Rollenspielen durch Freunde. Und weil man Dinge macht, die der große Bruder macht, hängt man sich da auch mit dran und hat mit, es war noch Grundschule, angefangen mit dem Rollenspiel und bin bei Hing geblieben. Und ja, hab halt gespielt und da haben sich die Spiele weiterentwickelt, wie man sich auch selber weiterentwickelt. Und irgendwann hab ich den Sörgen kennengelernt und hab mich davon überzeugt, dass es eine tolle Idee ist.
Ja, aber ich meine, wie... Klingt ja so ein bisschen wie Drogen nehmen, ne? So wie, ja, meine Freunde haben das alle gemacht. Hab ich das auch gemacht, bin ich hingegeblieben.
Ja, aber dann wäre Fernsehengucken doch auch Drogen nehmen.
Ja, ist es ja auch.
Ah, verdammt. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich guck schon seit Ewigkeit.
Ich meine, aber was ist denn das für einen Freundeskreis, der einen dann sozusagen da umzirzt?
Alles Mögliche.
Fantasy-Begeisterte würde ich als in erster Linie sagen.
Fantasy.
Fantasy-Begeisterte, ja. Ich glaube, die machen den größten Schwerpunkt in diesem Klientel aus.
Aber die kommen auch aus allen Lebensbereichen.
Jaja, klar, auf jeden Fall.
Wie würdet ihr das beschreiben, Fantasy? Was für Fantasien sind da im Staat?
Naja, Drachen, Helden, Magier, Magier, Hexen, so Tolkien und Co.
Genau, also das klassische Fantasy, das, was man unter dem Begriff in Film und Fernsehen, Literatur finden kann.
Drachen und Prinzessinnen sozusagen.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ja schon wieder fast bei den Computerspielen.
Ja, ein bisschen, natürlich.
Die haben das ja auch übernommen.
Genau, Rollenspiel bleibt Rollenspiel.
Ja, hier so vor ein paar Sendungen. Arcade-Games, nicht wahr? Da war ja auch so... Assassin-Retten mit Mario.
Ja, natürlich kann man die Konzepte weitaus weitschweifender machen. Weil man nicht nur Fantasy bespielt, sondern eventuell auch Science-Fiction oder Horror. Also was es an Büchergenre gibt, das gibt es auch an Rollenspielsystemen.
Natürlich. Du hast natürlich auch Science-Fiction und so in den Arcade-Games. Aber die Arcade-Games haben natürlich einen Nachteil. Die sind ziemlich gradlinig und bieten nur eine Spiel-Eigenschaft an. Meistens ist es, irgendwas abzuknallen und durch die Gegend zu bewegen. Rollenspiel ist da ein bisschen vielseitiger. Du hast da eine Interaktion mit Freunden. Meistens finden sich die Freunde am selben Tisch, im selben Haus und unterhalten sich ganz lustig über ihre Vorstellungen bezüglich ihrer Fantasy-Hintergründe in Form von Charakteren. Jeder dieser Spieler hat sozusagen ein... Wie sagt man das am besten?
Hat einen Charakter, den er bespielt.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt auf die Individualität zu sprechen kommen. Jeder hat seine ganz eigene Vorstellung, die er in seinem Charakter transportiert. Mit der wirkt er dann auf diese Geschichte, die ihm von dem... Ja, was sag ich jetzt? Mysteriös? Nein, ich tu's nicht. Von dem Spielleiter ganz einfach. Also derjenige, der die Geschichte erzählt. Auf diese Geschichte kann er dann einwirken mit diesem Charakter.
Also die Interaktion ist der große Unterschied.
Genau, das ist auch das Wichtige, denke ich.
Bevor wir dann vielleicht noch mehr ins Detail gehen, vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen einen Blick auf die Geschichte, wie sich das eigentlich so entwickelt hat. Weil heute gibt es das halt, aber es ist auch noch nicht so lange her, da gab es das irgendwie alles noch gar nicht. Also ich meine, gibt es da irgendwelche historischen Referenzen, wo die Leute schon so ähnliche Dinge getan haben?
Also früher, also es fing wohl alles damit an, dass man im 19. Jahrhundert angefangen hat, auf dem Brett Einheiten durch die Gegend zu schieben und Schlachten nachzuspielen.
Also Einheiten im Sinne von militärischen Einheiten.
Von militärischen Einheiten.
Also jetzt so richtig Militärplanung.
Strategie und Taktik.
Und dass man das halt auf dem Brett auch nachspielt. Und das hat sich über die Zeit auch getragen. Und es gab Gruppen, die das dann auch zum Beispiel auf mittelalterliche Schlachten übertragen haben, weil die Regelsysteme wurden immer komplexer und haben aber eher so den Krieg im 19. oder dann 20. Jahrhundert wiedergespiegelt. Und irgendwann kam dann JR. Tolkien mit dem Herrn der Ringe. Und auf einmal wollten die Leute halt nicht nur Mittelalter-Schlachten und Ähnliches haben, sondern auch noch Dämonen, Ballrocks und große Magier, die den Kampf beeinflussen.
Aber du meinst, das war ein Nachspielen von Ereignissen. Also gar nicht so sehr jetzt ein interaktives Spiel, was sich irgendwie entwickelt. Sondern es ging mehr ums, das weiß ich hier, die Oma-Kaffeekränzchen, die die Schlacht bei Midway darstellt.
Ja und nein. Einerseits wurde natürlich die Schlacht nachgespielt. Andererseits hat man natürlich immer versucht, das besser zu machen als der Kriegsherr, der die Schlacht geschlagen hat. So nach dem Motto, mein Napoleon gewinnt. Ah, verstehe. Natürlich hat da jeder dann, ja, das hat nicht stattgefunden. Die kleinen Streitigkeiten, die es heute bei diesen Spielen gibt, gab es damals ganz sicher auch. Und dann haben sie aber gesagt, das kennen wir jetzt alles, das ist langweilig, wir wollen ein bisschen mehr Spannung. Und dadurch versuchen wir das Ganze doch in ein unrealistisches und sehr viel freieres Setting zu bewegen.
Und Tolkien mit seinen Büchern, der Hobbit und dem Herrn der Ringe in der Folge, das war jetzt so ein Wendepunkt, oder?
Ja, genau, da wollte man auf einmal nicht mehr die Schlacht von Gettysburg nachspielen, sondern halt im Sleep. Genau.
Aber gab es denn, also ich meine, hat denn Tolkien dieses Genre jetzt wirklich komplett losgetreten? Oder muss das ja auch schon vorher irgendwie Ansatzweise gegeben haben?
Na ja, da Tolkien sich ganz, ganz großartig in den Mythologien bedient hat, gab es das natürlich vorher schon, aber nicht auf diese Art. Also man kann schon das auf Tolkien zurückführen.
Und dann sind die Leute auf die Ideen gekommen, dass man ja nicht spezielle Heldeneinheiten quasi bekommt und die zusätzliche Fähigkeiten haben gegenüber den anderen Militäreinheiten. Und dann kam man auf die Idee, dass man ja genau diese Helden bespielt und sich somit dann in die Helden reinbewegt. Und das ist die Grundlage für das moderne Rollenspiel.
Das heißt, man hat dann am Anfang auch die ganze Zeit nur der Herr der Ringe gespielt sozusagen?
Ja, so Fantasy-Setting halt.
Wobei natürlich Herr der Ringe sehr nahe liegt. Und wahrscheinlich ist, denn da gab es ja wieder diese großen Schlachten, die man ohnehin schon gespielt hat. Das heißt, ich denke, das war ein wichtiger Berührungspunkt.
Dass das sozusagen als Element auch darin vorkam und dann aber sozusagen das individuelle Einzug gehalten hat durch eben diese stärkere Konzentration auf die Figuren in dem Roman.
Genau, dass man halt eben sagen kann, okay, ich habe jetzt hier nicht die Franzosen, die halt irgendwie in Deutschland einfallen, sondern ich habe jetzt hier halt die Orks, die... Ja, okay, ich will hier natürlich keine Zuweisungen unternehmen. Aber halt im Prinzip so, dass man sagen kann, okay, Orks gegen Elfen, Orks gegen menschliche Völker. Huch, mein Kopfhörer.
Ach, sie schlatt sich. Ein Ring, sie zu knechten. Wann war denn das hier eigentlich? 54, 55 ging es los. In Deutsch erst deutlich später.
Mitte 60er Jahre mit der Umsetzung auf die WarGames-Rule und Anfang der 70er dieser Sprung auf das Heldentum. Das hatten dann Gary Gygax und James Arneson, heißt er, glaube ich. Die hatten halt auch ein Fantasy-Regel-Set und haben das nach Dungeons & Dragons bewegt. Gary Gygax kam ja auch schon öfter an den Simpsons vor, als alter Mann mit Würfeln, der dann irgendwie alles ausgewürfelt hat, bis er vor wenigen Jahren verstorben ist.
Genau, das war ganz groß an den Medien. Das hat sogar jeder Nicht-Rollenspieler mitbekommen können. Natürlich dann nicht gewusst, wer ist das für ein Typ.
Ja, ich hab's natürlich nicht mitbekommen.
Aber Gary Gygax ist so der Vater des Rollenspiels.
Es ist halt das D&D-Urgestein sozusagen. Der ist für alles verantwortlich.
Das heißt, diese beiden Jungs haben das Spiel namens Dungeons & Dragons entwickelt. Und das basiert quasi im Wesentlichen auf dieser Fantasy-Mythologie, wie man sie bei Herr der Ringe und später dann auch nicht nur dort fand. Und was ist dann sozusagen dabei rausgekommen? Also was war das?
Man hat halt die Helden aus den Cosims, aus den Wargames rausgenommen. Und hat sie jetzt allein durch die Gegend bewegt. Und weil das natürlich grundsätzlich total langweilig sein kann, hat man versucht, denen dann etwas entgegenzustellen. Monster, Fallen, Schätze, Ablenkung.
Was heißt, man hat sie bewegt?
Zunächst auf lustiges Karo-Papier erinnernde Dungeons. Das heißt, das war alles sehr, sehr quadratisch, sehr metermaß bzw. dann bei denen wahrscheinlich dann eher Fußmaß genommen.
Was hat man jetzt bekommen? Dungeons & Dragons war ja sozusagen so eine Box. Man konnte die kaufen.
Das war eine Box mit zwei lustigen Büchern drin. Für Spieler und für Spielleiter.
Charakterblätter waren, glaube ich, noch bei.
Ja, genau.
Die waren auch lustig, klein und bunt. Und Würfel waren, glaube ich... Nee, erst bei DSA waren Würfel dabei. Ich glaube, bei Dungeons & Dragons waren noch keine Würfel dabei.
Du brauchtest einen 20-Seiter. Es ist wahrscheinlich, dass da einer dabei war.
Ja, aber Bücher und ein paar Blatt Papier, wo die Vorgaben für den Charakter, also welche Eigenschaften und Charakter in diesem Spielsystem besitzt das Fahrt da schon drin.
Eigenschaften, Regeln, ein Entwicklungspfad für jede...
Klasse?
Ja, genau, kann man ja an dem Stelle erwähnen. Das heißt, das war alles in Klassen aufgegliedert. Es gab den klassischen Draufhaut, es gab den klassischen Rumzauber.
Okay, das ist ja jetzt schon eine relativ detaillierte Beschreibung. Aber was ist sozusagen das Set? Also was muss man sich jetzt vorstellen unter dem Begriff Rollenspiel? Was tut man? Wie viele Leute brauche ich? Was macht man konkret?
Na, man nimmt eine Figur an und bewegt sie durch eine Welt. Die Welt kann klein sein, ein Dungeon oder groß sein. Aber bei DSA ist das ja dann die ganze Welt.
Was heißt bewege sie?
Also ich habe in der Regel einen Spieleiter und optimalerweise zwischen drei und fünf Spielern. Das ist so das Set, was ich...
Wo nimmt man den Spieleiter her?
Der wird entweder bestimmt...
Einen Freiwilliger wird da mitgeliefert.
Genau, der kommt in der Box mit dabei, ist aber dann in dem Unterhalt ziemlich teuer. Nein, Quatsch beiseite natürlich. Der ist meistens ein Freiwilliger. Es gibt in jeder Anfängerrunde immer jemanden, der experimentierfreudig genug ist, zu sagen, ja, ich mach das. Und ich hab auch oft genug schon gesehen, dass der ausgelost wird. Dass die Leute sich treffen, spielen wollen, keiner will so richtig, und dann geht's los. Mach du doch mal.
Also einer muss sozusagen eine spezielle Rolle übernehmen.
Genau, das ist der Erzähler.
Der erzählt die Geschichte, übernimmt die Sinne der Charaktere und alle Statisten. Und die Charaktere von den Spielern gespielt sind die...
Und die Geschichte nimmt er dann aus dieser begleitenden Dokumentation.
Entweder...
Also grundsätzlich schon. Ob er dann sich weiterentwickelt und sich das selber ausdenkt, bleibt erst mal dahingestellt. Aber die meisten Rollenspiele liefern die Geschichte mit. Das heißt...
Versetzen wir uns einfach mal in die Situation, wir sind die ersten Leute auf diesem Planeten, die dieses erste Dungeons & Dragons-Spiel jetzt auf dem Tisch haben.
Dann gucken wir erst mal reichlich Blöde. Aber da wir wahrscheinlich Tolkien-begeistert sind, können wir mit den Worten wie Elf, Zwerg, Magier und Krieger schon ganz schön viel anfangen. Und deswegen... Das sind sozusagen......haben wir schon mal Interesse.
Heldenrollen, die man dann annehmen kann.
Bei D&D 1, ja, da waren sie das. Na und wo wird's noch? Was man halt aus 2G kennt.
Das heißt, der Spieleiter kriegt ja jetzt was anderes in die Hand als die anderen? Der muss ja dann irgendwas wissen, was die anderen nicht.
Genau, er kriegt ja sein Spieleiterbuch in die Hand, was ich eingehends erwähnte. Das ist halt ein Buch für Spieler und eins für Spieleiter dabei. Und im Spieleiterbuch stehen dann natürlich auch die Abenteuer drin, die er sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht selber ausdenken muss. Was ganz gut für den Spieleiter ist, denn er hat dadurch ganz konkrete Vorgaben und kann nun seine Monster durch die Gegend erdenken, die dort dann ihm vorgeschlagen werden.
Also was der Geigex und Amazon gemacht haben, ist sozusagen, sie haben ein Rahmenwerk geliefert, also ein Regelwerk auf der einen Seite, wie man spielt, was erst mal darauf basiert, dass man eben eine Person als Spieleiter, Meister oder wie heißt das dann konkret?
Spieleiter ist der generischte Begriff.
Original wird das ja dann...
Dungeon Monster. Also es ist tatsächlich komplett unterschiedlich, wo es herkommt und was sie dann sich ausgedacht haben. Ich meine, einige Spiele, auf die wir später eingehen werden, haben das dann Storyteller genannt, weil das treffender ist. Spieleiter ist natürlich regulierend. Dann gibt es Meister, der Böse, alles Mögliche, was man nicht ausdenken kann.
Auf jeden Fall nimmt eine andere Rolle ein. Und die anderen... Das heißt, in seiner Dokumentation wird dann erst mal so eine Geschichte erzählt, die er dann vorlesen kann, ohne sich das jetzt selber ausdenken zu müssen, wo dann so das Setting ist. Was weiß ich, ihr steht im Wald und ihr seid irgendwie zu fünft.
Hat er noch eine Karte von dem Bereich, der bespielt wird?
Eine Karte im Sinne von Landkarten.
Ja, in der Regel schon ein detaillierter Anlageplan, wo die Leute dann konkret durchgehen.
Aber den sehen die anderen jetzt nicht?
Ja, die können dann so Auto-Mapping-mäßig selber nachzeichnen.
Also dazu muss man sagen Ja und Nein. Es ist natürlich teilweise vorgesehen, das den Spielern auch konkret vorzulegen oder aufzumalen, damit die dann auch eine sehr genaue Vorstellung von der Umgebung haben und dann im Zweifel wieder, wie bei den Wargames, ihre Figuren durch die Gegend schubsen können und Monster hauen.
Und dann? Was passiert dann?
Dann kriegen sie Erfahrungspunkte. Also quasi...
Gleich zum Start oder was?
Nee, nee, also wenn sie natürlich ihre Herausforderungen geschafft haben, dann entwickeln sich diese Charaktere natürlich weiter.
Okay, aber wie werde ich denn erst mal so ein Charakter? Bestimmt dann der Spieleiter, was ich bin?
Manchmal.
Idealerweise nicht, aber manchmal.
In der Regel kann man dann... Also bei Dungeons & Dragons 1 hatte man mehrere Klassen zur Auswahl. Da konnte ich dann sagen, ich möchte gerne Krieger sein. Dann hat man sich am besten mit seiner Gruppe abgesprochen, dass es auch wirklich sich gut verteilt. Und ich nicht fünf Krieger habe, sondern vielleicht einen Krieger, einen Magier, einen Dieb. Der kam ja später. Damit ich einen Heiler habe und einen, der im Nahkampf draufhauen kann, einer, der im Fernkampf draufhauen kann. Dann habe ich einen Blatt.
Diese Charakter geben sozusagen unterschiedliche Fähigkeiten, Grundfähigkeiten. Das heißt, ein Krieger kann besser zuhauen und ein Priester kann besser beten.
Sie haben es schon richtig mit Wundern belegt.
Aber alle können im Prinzip alles machen, aber sie sind nur unterschiedlich disponiert, wie gut sie das können.
Nein, tatsächlich war das am Anfang so, dass einige Klassen Fähigkeiten gar nicht besaßen. Der Hau drauf konnte die Tür zwar einrennen, aber der Priester konnte damit relativ wenig anfangen. Er konnte es versuchen, aber hatte nahezu keine Chance. Der Dieb war der Einzige, der sagen konnte, ich lasse ein Schloss dran oder ich schaniere, ich mache da mal was. Also insofern hat man das schon ziemlich spezialisiert. Man hat ziemlich klar gesagt, diese Figur hat dieses Vorgehen, Schema und diese Fähigkeiten und soll dadurch ihre Gruppe unterstützen. Wenn die nicht dabei ist, hat die Gruppe natürlich Pech und muss es anders lösen. Dann gab es Möglichkeiten.
Aber wie drückt sich diese Eigenschaft konkret aus? Ich meine, dann muss ja der Spieleiter sagen, du versuchst dir jetzt mal die Tür aufzudrücken, aber du bist halt nur so ein blöder Elf. Das schaffst du eh nicht.
Tatsächlich, ja. Das war ziemlich klar erklärt. Man hat gesagt, die haben Eigenschaftswerte, meinetwegen Stärke, und der Elf war halt nur mal bloß ein blöder Elf und hat die Tür nicht aufgedrückt gekriegt. Der Krieger konnte sagen, guck mal hier, ich habe doppelt so viel Stärke wie du. Bam, Tür offen.
Und hat dann gewürfelt, man hat einen Zahlenwert, man weist diesen Eigenschaftswerten zahlen zu. Und würfelt dann... Damals 1 bis 20. Hängt vom Spiel ab. Bei Dungeons & Dragons ist es 1 bis 20.
Also das ist meine Eigenschaft sozusagen.
Man hat halt Eigenschaftswerte. Man ist sozusagen... Und die würfel ich aus? Ja und nein. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das bei D&D 1 so gemacht wurde. Später, bei den Folgespielen davon, wurde es gemacht. Aber ich glaube, bei D&D 1 stand es fest. Ich glaube, da war das dann relativ festgehalten.
Also es gibt halt diverse Wege über viele verschiedene Systeme, wie man diese Eigenschaftswerke festlegt. Es gibt welche, da hat man quasi so ein Template von einem Charakter, wo man dann noch ein bisschen was dran rumschrauben kann. Es gibt welche, da würfel ich konkret die Werte aus. Nehme ein paar Würfel, würfel das und jetzt habe ich Stärke 13. Und es gibt wiederum andere, die haben dann so ein freies Punktesystem, wo ich dann sagen kann, ja, ich gebe halt 20 Punkte für meine Stärke aus, aber nur 5 für Intelligenz. Weil mein Baba, wenn der halt dumm wie Brot ist, ist mir das egal. Aber dafür ist er halt richtig, richtig stark. Und wenn ich jetzt die Tür einrennen will, nehme ich den Würfel, den mir das System vorgibt. Da gibt es dann auch wieder viele verschiedene Methoden. Und muss dann damit einen Mindestwurf schaffen oder eine bestimmte Anzahl von Erfolgen. Also je nachdem, wie das ist. Aber ich nehme halt ein Würfel und Würfel und vergleiche das dann mit dem Wert, der auf meinem Blatt steht.
Genau. Also auch wieder eine rein statistische Geschichte. Weil man sagt, okay, ich habe eine bessere Chance, also versuche ich das.
Aber wodurch drückt sich dann konkret der Unterschied jetzt zwischen einem Krieger und einem nicht ganz so physikalisch?
Ein Krieger hat Stärke 15 und ein Elf hat Stärke 6.
Genau, die Eigenschaftswerte machen es dann.
Aber wenn ich das eh auswürfel, dann kann das ja auch genau andersrum sein.
Das kann natürlich sein. Wobei bei D&D 1 und kurzen Nachfolgern davon war festgelegt, dass man bestimmte Mindestwerte in verschiedenen Bereichen haben muss, um eine Klasse, also um sich für eine Qualasse zu qualifizieren. Der Krieger konnte also kein Krieger sein, wenn er nur eine Stärke 8 hatte.
Das heißt, man würfelt so lange, bis man eine Zahl hat, die passt.
Man verteilt es oder man muss sich für eine andere Klasse entscheiden. So lief es damals tatsächlich ab. Entweder man hat das ausgewürfelt und gesagt, ha ha, scheiße, ich hab jetzt blöde Werte, ich muss jetzt den Magier machen. Oder man hat gesagt, ich verteilt es jetzt so und hab blöde Werte, bin aber unwahrscheinlich stark.
Kurz dahin versucht man euch nicht zu sehr permanent zu unterbrechen, weil das für den Hörer dann ein bisschen anstrengend ist. Irgendwie darauf einigen, wer antwortet. Ich versuche das noch mal zusammenzufassen. Ich kriege sozusagen mein Set, da steht erst mal gar nichts drin. Ich muss erst mal festlegen, wer jetzt sozusagen der Spieleiter ist. Der Spieleiter kriegt dann das Heftchen, wo quasi die Geschichte drin ist. Es gibt wahrscheinlich mehrere. Da suche ich mir dann irgendwie eine spaßige aus. Und der Rest entscheidet sich in irgendeiner Form für ich möchte das werden, ich möchte das werden, das werden. Und dann werden erst mal die Eigenschaften ausgewürfelt. Das heißt, ich bestimme, wie mein Charakter so konkret drauf ist. Dann ist das sozusagen gesetzt und dann geht die Geschichte los. Und der Spieleiter sagt, ihr seid jetzt da und da. Und ihr schaut euch um und überall sind grüne Tannenwälder. Und jetzt kommt mal klar.
Genau. Und dann kommt dann irgendwann zumindest der spannende Teil für die meisten Spieler, nämlich es passiert was. Es passiert was Unfallhergesehenes oder es passiert etwas Kompliziertes, das gelöst werden muss. Das kann dann reichen von Monstern, Fallen, Rätsel über. Man trifft einzelne Personen, die etwas von einem wollen. Also natürlich vorgegeben vom Spieleiter. Und durch diese Begebenheit bewegt man sich dann hindurch. Man versucht dieses Thema zu lösen. Sei es nun Monster bekämpfen, fallen, entschärfen oder halt reinlaufen. Mit Leuten reden. Neuere Systeme haben das ganz freigestaltet. Damals war das noch so, dass es bei den Personen, denen man begegnet ist, sogar die richtigen Fragen stellen musste. Sonst passierte da gar nichts.
Sonst reagieren die gar nicht.
Na, die reden halt einfach nicht mit einem. Sonst sagen die, nö, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, geh weg.
Und so ein Verhalten ist dann in der Meisterliteratur auch schon vorgegeben. Aber muss da nicht derjenige, der dann...
Wie gesagt, damals war das noch so, in den 60ern, 70ern, als man dann festgestellt hat, wir fangen jetzt mal an mit solchen Ideen. Inzwischen ist es natürlich so, dass man Themen vorgibt. Dass man sagt, wenn der Spieler dies und jenes wissen will, kannst du ihm das sagen, wenn und so weiter.
Beziehungsweise, man gibt nur noch vor, das ist quasi der Nichtspieler-Charakter, der Statist mit dem Namen, das ist so ein bisschen Hintergrund, den er hat, und er weiß das, das und das. Und wenn die Spieler dann auf diesen Statisten treffen oder nach diesen Informationen suchen, werden sie irgendwie auf diesen Nichtspieler-Charakter treffen. Und werden ihnen dann in der Regel schon die richtigen Fragen irgendwie stellen, weil man ja weiß, was sie, weil sie ja eh schon durch ihre Suche nach diesen Informationen auf diese Person gestoßen sind.
Mach mal so mal ein bisschen konkreter. Spielen wir das doch mal durch. Wenn wir Rollenspieler sind, dann können wir das ja auch irgendwie... Ach, Quatsch, mach mal nicht. Also ich meine, wir sind jetzt irgendwie im Wald. Was wäre jetzt so eine typische Prädisposition? Was könnte jetzt sozusagen, was könnte sein? Was könnte für eine Situation... Womit würdet ihr das Spiel eröffnen, wenn ihr jetzt so die Meister wärt, um die Sache irgendwie mystisch zu machen?
Ja, ich kann da gleich mal einen meiner kürzlich erlebten Spieleiter wiedergeben. Und er sagte zu seinen Spielern, als ihr da so dieses Weges kommt, seht ihr im Wald, so halb durchs Unterholz, ein Lagerfeuer, über dem ein kleiner Mensch baumelt und zwei richtig hässliche, super ranzige Schurken sitzen. Und das sieht wohl so aus, als wollen die den kleinen Menschen gleich essen. Ja, und da bist du natürlich gefordert als Spieler, wie was, Menschen essen.
Kann einem doch egal sein, oder?
Ja, natürlich, vollkommen legitim, dass dir das egal ist. Aber so werden natürlich keine Helden gemacht. Ein erfahrener Rollenspieler weiß dann, wenn ich das jetzt löse, werde ich dafür belohnt in Form von Erfahrungspunkten. Mein Charakter entwickelt sich weiter. Vielleicht gibt es Schätze.
Ah, Erfahrungspunkte.
Genau, vielleicht, wenn ich diesen kleinen Menschen rette, dann kommt er mit, hilft mir. Also, da gibt es allerlei Möglichkeiten und Wege, die Spieler dann schon...
Das heißt, Erfahrungspunkte, das sind eigentlich so die kleinen Pac-Man-Punkte, die man essen möchte die ganze Zeit.
Das sind die kleinen Pac-Man-Punkte, die man unbedingt haben möchte und denen man hinterherrennt. Und für die man dann halt große Liegegeister fährt.
Aber man weiß nicht vorher, was ein Erfahrungspunkt oder mehrere für mich bringen könnte.
Doch, schon. Also, es ist vom System ja vorgegeben. Und auch der Spieler weiß, wann er etwas mit seinen Punkten erreichen kann.
Wann er was mit seinen Punkten erreichen kann, aber nicht, wann er neue Punkte erreicht.
Er kann nicht genau wissen, wann er die kriegt und wofür und wie viele. Manche Systeme sind da sehr transparent und sagen dem Spieler, du wirst für diese Spielrunde heute bestimmt so und so viele Punkte kriegen. Und da kannst du eigentlich machen, was du willst. Hauptsache, du setzt deinen Charakter sinnvoll ein.
Und wie vielstellig sind die Erfahrungspunkte üblicherweise?
Das ist von System zu System sehr unterschiedlich.
Ist das nicht so wie bei Flippern, dass man gleich eine Million kriegt?
Ich kenne Systeme, da sagt man zwischen 4 und 7 pro Spielabend. Und es gibt Systeme, da kriegt man dann bei sehr hochgradigen Charakteren irgendwie so einen vierstelligen Bereich Erfahrungspunkte pro Spielabend oder höher sogar.
Also das hängt dann schon wieder mit der Entwicklung des Charakters ab, wie gut ist der inzwischen schon und so.
Was hat er denn dann gemacht mit dem kleinen Menschen, der über dem Feuer baumelt?
Wir haben ihn befreit. Ich hatte damals tatsächlich einen Elfen gespielt.
Also ich meine, wie viele Leute mussten sozusagen...
In der Spielrunde, ich glaube, wir waren fünf. Genau, ich hatte den Elfen gespielt, tatsächlich den losgeschossen und der ist dann sogar nebensfeuer geplumpst, weil ich total verrafft hatte, dass der ja da baumelt, um gebraten zu werden.
Also geschossen mit Pfeil und Bogen sozusagen.
Genau, ich hab den dann halt quasi freigeschossen, der hat sich dann selbst befreien können, also entfesseln können, mit meinem Pfeil weitergekämpft und die anderen haben in der Zwischenzeit...
Das war schon alles, also du musstest sozusagen nur auf die Idee kommen, so, ah, da baumelt einer, dann nehm ich doch mal meinen Pfeil und Bogen und schieß einfach.
Na, es war eine Möglichkeit, die man das lösen konnte. Man hätte natürlich auch erst die Schurken umlegen und dann den Halbling befreien können. Wäre vielleicht für den ein bisschen warm geworden, aber für uns bequemer oder so. Ich weiß es gar nicht genau, was sich da vorgestellt hat. Auf jeden Fall war der Halbling sogar einer der späteren Spieler. Also, es war...
Halbling, was ist denn noch mal ein Halbling?
Ein Halbling. Wer sich jetzt also an Tolkien erinnert, da kommen Hobbits vor und die gehören zur größeren Klasse der Halblinge. Dazu gehören mehrere von diesen kleinen Menschlingen, die, ja, nur halb so groß sind.
So Minimis.
Der wird sich ärgern, wenn er das hört.
Aber der Begriff Halbling zum Beispiel wurde auch eingeführt, ursprünglich bei Dungeons & Dragons 1, in der ganz ursprünglichen Fassung hießen die auch noch Hobbits, bis die Firma, also der Verlag, der hinter Tolkien stand, angefangen hat zu klagen. Und daraufhin entschied man es dann, den Halbling umzubenennen.
Ernsthaft, ja. Es taucht immer mal wieder auf das Wort Hobbit, aber meistens nur in der weiträumigeren Erklärung, was denn Halblinge alles sein können.
Aber in dieser Runde, ich meine, du hast jetzt beschlossen, gleich loszuschießen. Die anderen hätten ja auch erst mal was tun können. Wer bestimmt denn jetzt überhaupt, wer als nächstes was tun darf? Oder ist das dann so wie in der Schule, alle melden sich und ich, ich, ich?
In dieser Runde, in der ich gespielt habe, war es tatsächlich so ein bisschen wie in der Schule. Das heißt, alle haben sich gemeldet und ich hatte das große Glück, dem Spieleiter genau im Blickfeld zu sitzen. Und deswegen hat er gesagt, na dann mach du doch mal. Und ich so, ja klar, hier, peng.
Es ist jetzt nicht so eine Mensch-Ärger-den-ich-Runde, wo jeder sozusagen nacheinander irgendwie einen Spielzug machen darf.
Und doch, grundsätzlich ist das sehr reguliert. Das heißt, es gibt etwas, das nennt sich Initiative-Regelung. Das heißt, irgendwie wird festgestellt, meistens durch einen Würfelwurf, wer zuerst handeln darf. Und dann wird in einer Reihenfolge dieser Werte, die man sich erwürfelt hat, halt gehandelt. Und dann kann man auch sehen, ob man vor oder nach den Monstern ist oder so. Das erzeugt dann das Gefühl von Fairness.
Was für ein Würfel muss man da werfen? Da gibt es ja dann auch verschiedene Würfel.
Ja, wieder systemabhängig, wie alles. Meistens wird es dann geklärt über einen 20-seitigen Würfel, auf dem natürlich alles möglich ist, von 1 bis 20. Und dann hat man da seine Einteilung und man fängt halt bei 20 an. Geht runter, manchmal geht man auch von 1 hoch. Also, wie gesagt, sehr abhängig vom System.
Aber es gibt auch Systeme mit W100, oder wo ich viele Würfel, viele 6-seitige Würfel werfe.
Mit W100.
Ja, also W100 bedeutet 100-seitiger. W-Zahl bedeutet Würfel mit so viel.
Ein 100-seitiger Würfel.
Na, nicht wirklich.
Also es sind dann in der Regel zwei W10, wo ich dann eine 10er-Stelle und eine 100er-Stelle habe. Oder es gibt auch so fast kugelförmige... Also W100 gibt es wirklich als Würfel. Die sind aber nicht so gut lesbar. Ja, ja.
Das ist mir auch nicht zu empfehlen. Die rollen durch die ganze Wohnung.
Ja, ja, würde ich gerade sagen. Die rollen auch dann ewig durch die Gegend.
Genau.
Und bleiben die dann überhaupt richtig liegen? Weiß man da überhaupt noch, was oben ist?
Man kann es ziemlich gut erkennen sogar. Aber man braucht natürlich Hilfsmittel. Es gibt ziemlich findige Spieler, die haben ein Würfelbord. Das heißt, sie haben so etwas, das sieht aus wie in einer Kneipe, wo die Getränke drin rumgetragen werden. Die sind dann auch schön mit Sand ausgeklebt. Und da drin wird dann gewürfelt. Da gibt es einen Rand und da können die Würfel nicht endlos weit rollen. Natürlich ist das dann schwierig, weil wenn so ein W100 irgendwo an der Kante liegt, kann das schnell mal passieren, dass er nicht ganz auf seiner doch so kleinen Ablagefläche liegt.
Aber der bevorzugte Weg von W100 sind die zwei W10. Aber es geht halt wirklich los, je nach System, beim W2, sprich eine Münze. Ja, und beim W100 ist Schluss. Doch, ich habe auch schon mal...
Ein W1000.
Ja, es gibt Regelsysteme mit einem W1000, die halt Promelwerte gegebenenfalls wieder spiegeln.
Das sind so Wahrscheinlichkeiten, die man dann auswürfelt.
Ja, na klar, immer. Es sind immer Wahrscheinlichkeiten, genau.
Die Frage ist nur, ob es linear ist oder sich eher... Also mit Würfelpools bewegt man es halt eher auf so einer Normalverteilung hin und her. Das ist diese Glockenkurve. Und bei...
Also Würfelpools muss man an der Stelle vielleicht mal kurz erklären. Wie kommt es dazu und wann verwendet man sie?
Würfelpools sind halt, dass ich eine größere Anzahl von Würfeln werfe. Also z.B. W6, dass ich sage... Es gibt z.B. Systeme, die sagen, ich habe einen bestimmten Wert für den Charakter. Der hat Stärke 6. Und dann bekomme ich, wenn ich eine Probe auf Stärke mache, 6 Würfel, halt 6 W6. Und würfel dann mit denen und muss dann z.B.
6 Würfeln würfelst du? 6 Würfel, A6, also normale...
Genau, und dann heißt es z.B. ich muss eine 4 schaffen. Und dann muss ich halt auf mindestens 1 Würfel eine 4 zeigen.
Was bei 6 Würfeln ja sehr wahrscheinlich ist.
Also mindestens eine 4 zeigen.
Genau, mindestens eine 4. Oder es heißt z.B. es muss mindestens eine 4 zeigen, aber davon brauchst du eine 3-Erfolge. Sprich...
Aber warum würfelt man mit so vielen? Da würde ja ein Würfel auch ausreichen.
Das hängt halt vom System ab. Aber mit 6 Würfeln, wenn ich halt meine Eigenschaften über diese Würfel-Puls darstelle, bekommt halt jemand, der schwach ist, bei stärker 1 nur einen 6-seitigen Würfel. Und jemand, der stark ist, bekommt 6 6-seitige Würfel. Und wenn ich dann umso mehr Würfel ich habe, umso höher ist die Chance, diese Zahl zu erreichen.
Um auf das Beispiel mit der Tür von vorhin zurückzukommen, dann hat halt der 11 jetzt einen 6-seitigen Würfel und benötigt eine 5.
Warte mal, Beispiel mit der Tür?
Mit der Tür einrennen. Also, 11 von ganz vorhin, also 11 will Tür einrennen und Krieger will es. Und der 11 hat dann halt nur einen Sonnenwürfel, muss eine 5 erreichen auf dem 6-Seiter. Das heißt, 33-prozentige Wahrscheinlichkeit. Und der Kämpfer hat dann halt 4 und muss eine 5 erreichen. Okay, Wahrscheinlichkeit schwach. Nein, also, ist halt schon viel wahrscheinlicher. Also, insofern...
Okay, das heißt, diese Eigenschaften, die man sich am Anfang so erwürfelt hat und die dann je nach Charakter eben sowieso erstmal so in einem bestimmten Range liegen, werden dann im Laufe des Spiels noch ergänzt durch eben die... Also, diese Würfelpools, die richten sich dann sozusagen nur nach dem Charakter. Oder richtet sich sowas auch noch nach Erfahrungspunkten? Oder wie...
Na ja, mit Erfahrungspunkten wird mein Charakter halt besser und stärker und je nach... Also, irgendwie steigen meine Werte an. Die Zahlen, die ich da habe, werden größer und damit habe ich dann mehr Würfel oder eine... Wenn ich zum Beispiel so ein lineares Wahrscheinlichkeitssystem habe, wie bei Dungeons & Dragons und das heißt, ich muss irgendwas unter Würfeln zum Beispiel und mein Charakter hat mit einer 10 angefangen und wenn die Standard-Probe ist, schaffe diese 10, dann muss ich halt mit einem... habe ich eine 50%ige Chance mit einem W20. Und wenn mein Charakter besser wird und der irgendwann eine 15 zum Beispiel auf diesen Wert hat und ich dann standardmäßig die 15 unter Würfeln muss, habe ich auf einmal eine 75%ige Chance.
Aber man benutzt sozusagen Würfel und Würfelpools generell, um einfach Wahrscheinlichkeiten auszudrücken und jeder Move, den ich mache, muss halt auf der einen Seite, um erfolgreich zu sein, erstmal so das Richtige sein, im Sinne des Spielverlaufs. Das weiß dann in dem Zweifelsfall nur der Spielleiter. Und es muss dann sozusagen die konkrete Maßnahme dann auch noch gelingen. Und die hängt dann eben von meinen Eigenschaften ab oder von meinem Charakter oder vom Bodennebel oder von der Mondphase. Das kann ja auch sein. Und damit das dann gelingt. Und wenn ich das dann sozusagen geschafft habe, wenn ich also diese Wahrscheinlichkeit erreicht habe, dann wird mir dann der Erfolg zugesprochen.
Genau. Ich möchte noch kurz darauf hinweisen, das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen verwirrend, feste Werte und Würfelpuls kommen nicht nebeneinander vor. Das heißt, in dem Augenblick, wo ich mir meine Startwerte eventuell auswürfe, werde ich nicht auf Würfelpuls zurückgreifen. Das heißt, das sind zwei völlig unterschiedliche Systeme. Würfelpuls kommen in Systemen vor, wo viele Werte miteinander verknüpft werden. Und man versucht, so einen einfachen Überblick zu ermöglichen, dass ich, wenn ich gegebenenfalls Attribute, Fertigkeiten und noch Kram verbinden soll, dass ich dann einfach sage, nehme ich die Würfel und noch ein paar und noch ein paar und jetzt weiß ich, wie viel ich letztendlich habe. Feste Werte, die natürlich auch mit irgendetwas verbunden werden können, wie Fertigkeiten, werden dann nicht noch mit einem Würfelpool bedacht, weil die sind schon relativ offensichtlich und fest vorgegeben. Das heißt, in dem Fall ist es häufiger so, dass ich einfach nur versuche, den bestehenden Wert zu erreichen, zu unterwürfeln oder Ähnliches. Das heißt, mit einem Würfel, um meinen Erfolgsgrad festzustellen.
Im Rollenspiel-Phänomen wird ja immer gerne unterstellt, dass es sehr populär unter Nerds und so ist. Mag das irgendwie an dieser Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung liegen? Also gewisse Zahlenfaszinationen von ausgeht. Aber das ist ja im eigentlichen Sinne nicht kompliziert. Das ist sozusagen, man muss sich die Vorgehensweise einmal vergegenwärtigen. Und dann besteht im Prinzip jeder Spielzug nur noch dadurch, gelingt mir das jetzt oder gelingt mir das nicht. Und das ergibt sich sozusagen aus Zufall versus meiner Disposition. Und im Mittelpunkt steht aber der eigentliche Spielfortschritt, sozusagen das Hin und Her zwischen dem Spieleiter und den anderen Charakteren.
Genau. Also rein theoretisch geht das sogar alles ohne Würfel.
Nein, nicht nur rein theoretisch. Es gibt tatsächlich Spiele, die sehen Würfel nicht vor.
Gar nicht.
Da läuft alles auf einer Basis von Kommunikation. Das heißt, wenn ich das gut genug beschreiben kann, dann wird das auch gelingen.
Wie viele Systeme gibt es denn so auf dem Markt, die so verabtreten sind?
Aktuell auf dem Markt liegt die Zahl zwischen 50 und 70 Spielen. Tatsächlich ist die Zahl viel größer, denn es gibt Spiele, die sind nicht frei erhältlich, beziehungsweise dann doch frei erhältlich und nicht auf dem Markt erhältlich. Oder es gibt sie schon nicht mehr. Also es ist da eine große Fluktuation.
Was machen sie denn mit frei erhältlich? Also im Netz?
Im Netz, genau. Es ist als freies, kostenloses Regelwerk. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Spiele, die von Einzelpersonen gemacht wurden oder auch Gruppierungen. Und die dann gesagt haben, nö, ach, warum denn? Hier, das ist cool, das sollen wir alle spielen.
Aber was sind denn jetzt sozusagen die populären Systeme? Ich meine, Dungeons & Dragons war... Ist so der Klassiker eigentlich? Und ist das sozusagen auch immer noch...
Genau.
Immer noch so das dominante System? Oder ist das irgendwie alles abgelöst worden?
Na, dominant würde ich so nicht sagen. Das hängt wieder davon ab, wo man sich befindet. In Deutschland ist das ein bisschen anders.
Also Dungeons & Dragons ist an sich schon... Also weltweit der Marktführer, denke ich mal. Also das liegt aber auch daran, dass die Firma, die heutzutage dahinter steht, sehr, sehr gut da drin ist, das Ganze zu vermarkten und damit Geld zu verdienen. Natürlich gibt es noch andere Systeme. In Deutschland ist zum Beispiel auch das schwarze Auge.
Also die Firma ist auch immer noch dieselbe.
Nein, das ist inzwischen Wizards of the Coast. Die sind noch bekannt halt für Magic. Das ist ein Trading Card Game. Was, glaube ich, auch schon mal bei einem Brettspielen erwähnt worden ist.
Ja, so am Rande, aber so richtig darauf eingegangen sind.
Ja, und die sind halt richtig groß. Und die besitzen zurzeit die Rechte an Dungeons & Dragons und machen da die ganzen Regelwerke und Spielhilfen und so weiter. Denn in Deutschland ist noch das schwarze Auge sehr groß, was es seit Anfang der 80er, Anfang Mitte der 80er Jahre gibt. Und in Deutschland ist die Chance auch sehr hoch, dass wenn man damit anfängt, bzw. auch früher mal damit angefangen hat, dass es das schwarze Auge ist. Also weil es eben früher sogar mal im Karstadt oder sonst wo verkauft worden ist. Regular im 80er Jahre. Heute nicht mehr, oder was? Nee, heute gibt es Rollenspiele fast ausschließlich in spezialisierten Läden. Man findet es teilweise noch in größeren Buchhandlungen oder ähnlichem, aber im Kaufhaus findet man Rollenspiele eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Warum?
Da würde ich jetzt sagen, die Verkaufszahlen für die Kaufhäuser sind nicht gut genug. Es bringt halt nichts, wenn ich nur 10 Stück davon bestelle und verkaufe, sondern wenn will ich das ja natürlich im größeren Stil machen. Und die Leute, die vorbeikommen und gucken, was gibt es denn so Neues, sind dann, naja, wie soll ich sagen, nicht so... Ja, nein, sie können damit nichts anfangen. Sie gucken sich das halt an und denken sich so, ja, und was ist das? Und genau da werden halt die spezialisierteren Geschäfte wichtig, denn da steht dann nämlich jemand rum, der einem das erklärt. Was ist das und wofür ist das gut?
Ich denke, man braucht wohl auch eine bestimmte Einstellung zu dem Spiel. Nicht grundsätzlich. Aber ich meine, man spielt das ja jetzt nicht nur so, dass man da irgendwie seine Kärtchen durchliest und dann spielt man das so runter und würfelt ein bisschen, sondern hier muss man sich ja was einfallen lassen. Also ich meine, hier ist es ja sozusagen in hohem Maße so eine Echtzeitinterpretation der Züge. Ich meine, da mag ja jetzt genau drinstehen, naja, wenn der Elf beschließt, das Band mit dem Pfeil durchzuschießen, dann das. Kann aber auch sein, dass dieser Pfeil, den du dir jetzt gerade ausgedacht hast, so überhaupt gar nicht abgedeckt ist. Da muss man sich ja im Prinzip was einfallen lassen. Man muss das ja dann sozusagen im Kontext interpretieren. Also worauf ich hinaus will, sind Rollenspieler jetzt irgendwie anders drauf als Leute, die Brettspieler oder was weiß ich spielen?
Grundsätzlich gar nicht. Also tatsächlich kann ich aus meinem größeren Bekenntenkreis sagen, dass nahezu alle Rollenspieler auch irgendwie mit Brettspielen was anfangen können. Ist ja schließlich ein sehr ähnliches System. Also ich habe Wahrscheinlichkeiten, ich versuche, was zu erreichen. Viele Brettspiele heutzutage sind ja auch vom ursprünglichen Mensch ärgere dich nicht oder so weggekommen, sondern stellen halt auch eine größere Bandbreite an Tätigkeiten, Möglichkeiten da. Insofern, nö, eigentlich so groß der Unterschied nicht. Das Problem ist nur, dass viele Rollenspiele bieten das nicht dem Neueinsteiger so offensichtlich an, dass es leicht, einfach und spaßig ist. Das heißt, es wirkt so, als müsste man sich das erst mal komplett einlesen, um das spielen zu können.
Und ich bekomme dann heutzutage bei vielen Systemen irgendwie so ein Buch, die nach vier Größe, drei bis vierhundert Seiten, und das ist halt gegenüber einem Brettspiel-Regelwerk, was ein kleines Heftchen ist, natürlich eine ganz andere Sache. Und wenn ich mir das jetzt als...
300 bis 400 Seiten. Wobei man kriegt ja so einen kompletten Herr der Ringe da eingelegt.
Die muss man immer durchlesen. Na ja, eins der Bücher.
Was steht denn da alles drin? Also ich meine, wieviel davon muss man denn da lesen, bis man da überhaupt klarkommt?
Lesen müssen tut man grundsätzlich eigentlich davon reichlich wenig. Man sollte es lesen, um den Leuten das Leben zu erleichtern, die einem helfen. Weil wenn man sich das alles erzählen lässt, dann braucht man es natürlich gar nicht lesen. Das ist ganz einfach, machen viele, ist nicht so schön. Man sollte sich durchlesen, was denken die sich dabei. Also zum Beispiel die Kapitel, was ist Rollenspiel? Wie sieht unsere Welt aus? Und was kannst du in dieser Welt darstellen? Und bei dem, was kannst du in dieser Welt darstellen, kommen wir auch dann direkt zu dem Punkt Charaktere. Da ist meistens eine Charakter- erschaffung enthalten, die sehr detailliert erklärt, wie man seinen Charakter aufbauen kann, um das zu erhalten, was man gerne möchte. Was man sich selber gerne vorstellt. Und wenn man das alles gelesen hat, dann ist man eigentlich schon spielfertig. Alles, was dann weiter in dem Buch drin steht, sind Hintergründe, Spielleiterinformationen, vielleicht Monster.
Ausrüstung, genaure Beschreibungen der Eigenschaften. Eventuell liegt noch ein Abenteuer dabei. Das ist heutzutage eher selten. Früher war das noch häufiger. Heute gibt es eher selten Beispiele, Abenteuer und Grundregelwerk.
Das heißt, man beschränkt sich mehr auf die eigentliche Systematik. Es beschreibt mehr ein Regelwerk, als dass es jetzt wirklich so ein Storytelling ist.
Das kommt auf das System drauf an. Es gibt auch welche, die sagen zum Beispiel, wir haben erstmal 100 Seiten Weltbeschreibung. Also 100 Seiten, wo erstmal beschrieben wird, zum Beispiel bei einem Science-Fiction-Spiel, welche Planeten gibt es, welche Regierungen gibt es auf diesem Planeten, wie reist man zwischen den Planeten, wie funktioniert das überhaupt, habe ich noch Geld, habe ich kein Geld? Und dann kommt irgendwie, das kannst du übrigens in dieser Welt spielen. Also ein Politiker will man vielleicht nicht unbedingt spielen, Attentäter ist dann eventuell interessanter.
Ja, ja, alles das, was man im realen Leben lieber bleiben lässt.
Und wenn du deinen Attentäter spielen willst, dann baust du ihn ja übrigens so mit unseren Regeln zusammen und so funktionieren unsere Regeln. Und dann gibt es einen Kapitel Kampf. So funktionieren, wenn du in Kampfsituationen kommst, so funktionieren die Kampfregeln. Das ist mit der dickste Regelteil in der Regel.
Wobei der Einsteigerspieler sich den noch nicht durchlesen braucht. Denn es gibt immer Erfahrene oder den Spieleiter, der dann leider dazu verpflichtet ist. Weil irgendwer muss leider wissen, wie das Ganze abläuft. Und das hängt dann so am Spieleiter.
Kampf ist das Umfangreichste. Wird denn so viel gekämpft, die ganze Zeit?
Häufig. Nicht die ganze Zeit, aber häufig. Es ist ein integraler Bestandteil fast jeden Rollenspiels.
An der Stelle kommt dann sozusagen auch wieder die Vergangenheit hervor. Wie die zehn Soldaten.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Ja, das ist dann auch wirklich durchgeregelt mit Initiative-Regeln. Und wie lange es dann eine Kampfrunde ist. Jetzt drei Sekunden oder fünf Sekunden. Und wie viel kann ich in diesem Zeitraum machen? Und meine Aktion...
In Sekunden ist das aufgeteilt?
Das kommt aufs System drauf an. Oftmals ist es in Sekunden aufgeteilt. Also neuere Systeme bringen jetzt auch sowas wie narrative Erzählzeit oder halt die dramatische Länge rein. Wie lange ist das Alien im Körper eines Menschen? Dramatisch lange.
Dramatisch lange.
Von einem bis zum nächsten Drama.
Klingt so wie Dauer von Podcast-Episoden.
Ja, genau dramatisch.
Könnte auch dramatisch lange werden. Vielleicht nochmal kurz zurück zu dem, er hat ja gefragt, was gibt es denn für Systeme jetzt? Hast du gesagt, es gibt Dungeons & Dragons, es gibt Dungeons & Dragons, es gibt schon Lange, es gibt sowas wie ich in der wievielten Iteration mittlerweile. Dann gibt es das schwarze Auge, vor allem in Deutschland. Die sind aber beide jetzt sozusagen in derselben Fantasy-Welt verortet im Wesentlichen.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Jedes System schreibt sich auf die Fahne, eigene Welten zu liefern oder eine eigene Welt zu liefern. Das heißt, D&D hat seine mehreren eigenen Welten und DSA hat seine eigene Welt, auf der viel passiert. Und auch wenn Spieler gerne sowas vermischen, da haben sie Spaß dran, finde ich auch gut so, möchten das, glaube ich, die Redakteure dahinter nicht so gern sehen. Das heißt, das ist schon alles ziemlich strukturiert.
Das heißt, es gibt bei D&D verschiedene Universen, die aber klar definiert sind. Man kann sich innerhalb dieser Universen immer wieder was Neues einfallen lassen.
Genau. Wichtig ist auch, dass viele Aspekte des Fantasy-Lebens unterschiedlich sein können. Dass Monster anders sein können, dass Dinge unterschiedlich viel kosten können oder Magie unterschiedlich häufig sein kann.
Wie viele unterschiedliche Universen heißt das überhaupt so? Wie nennt man das überhaupt irgendwie? Welten?
Welten.
Welten, wie viele Welten gibt es bei Dungeons & Dragons so?
Oh Gott, da müsste ich jetzt anfangen zu zählen. Es gibt reichlich. Also schon allein mit dem Klassiker Forgotten Realms, wozu es eine ganz tolle Büchereihe gibt, mit alten Welten wie Dark Sun oder neueren Welten wie Living Greyhawk, gibt es da eine ganze Menge. Also drei sollen jetzt mal gut Beispiel sein. Fällt mir jetzt auf Annie was ein. Ja, Ravenloft gibt es noch. Also es gibt da ein paar sehr, sehr interessante, sehr schöne Welten.
Aber es bewegt sich jetzt aber in einem niedrigen, zweistelligen Bereich, jetzt nochmal so ein Gefühl zu bekommen. Es gibt jetzt nicht Hunderte oder so.
Es steht jedem frei, seine eigene Welt zu machen. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass einige zukaufbare Hefte und Bücher ihre eigene Welt mitliefern. Aber grundsätzlich unter zweistelligem Bereich ist es okay.
Aber es ist natürlich auch ein Anreiz, jetzt sagen wir mal, einen dieser in Anführungsstrichen vorgefertigten Welten zu nehmen, weil da einfach schon viel durchdacht ist.
Natürlich. Ich kriege mein Hintergrundmaterial geliefert. Ich brauche mir da nicht tiefgründige Gedanken zu machen. Und Spieler suchen genau diese tiefgründigen Sachen ganz häufig. So was wie, warum ist der König denn jetzt so?
Okay, könnt ihr mal so eine der Welten vielleicht mal so exemplarisch hervorziehen, um mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was diese Welt dann so alles absteckt?
Nun, exemplarisch. Da müsste ich ja jetzt dann Forgotten Realms nehmen. Forgotten Realms ist im Prinzip ein großer Kontinent.
Warum musst du das nehmen?
Weil es die häufig bespielte und sehr bekannte Welt ist. Ich kann jetzt natürlich auch einige andere nehmen.
Ist das die, die es von Anfang an gab?
Ich glaube, es ist nicht die Urwelt. Ich glaube, sie hatten am Anfang keine echte Welt, keine eigene. Das ist dann aufgetaucht mit einigen Romanen, dass man gesagt hat, man nimmt eine feste Welt, in der was passiert, in der Persönlichkeiten auftauchen, die den Spielern begegnen können, wo ein Wiedererkennungswert stattfindet.
Das hat mit Dragonlands, glaube ich, angefangen. Ich glaube, Dragonlands war so das erste. Das war eine Romanreihe, die halt Dungeons & Dragons als Basis hatte und die dann eine Welt geschaffen hat.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher. Ich glaube, dass Forgotten Realms vorher da war. Das heißt, sie hatten einen Hintergrundsetting geschaffen für die Spiele und dann angefangen, diese Dragonlands-Reihe sich dazu zu erdenken.
Okay, ich schildere noch mal. Also, was gehört jetzt dazu? Was definiert diese Welt jetzt für mich?
Diese Welt definiert, dass sie einen großen Kontinent haben, auf dem so ziemlich alles passiert und so ziemlich alles Platz hat. Es gibt dort viele Sachen, die an Europa erinnern, beziehungsweise dann Randgebiete Afrika und so mit, Wüsten, was es so gibt.
Das heißt, es definiert Länder, es definiert Städte.
Es definiert Länder und Städte, Kulturen.
Auch sowas wie jetzt Straßen und Wege, Verbindungen, Abstände zwischen diesen?
Abstände Straßen, ja. Kleine, nein. Wobei sie viele Städte tatsächlich kartografiert haben, gesagt haben, so sieht diese Stadt aus. Als kleines Beispiel, Neverwinter Nights spielt in Forgotten Realms. Das heißt, diese Stadt Niewinter, die da ja vorkommt, ist schon vor dem Computerspiel entsprechend kategorifiert gewesen.
Warte mal, welches Computerspiel meinst du jetzt?
Ja, okay, also eins der Computer-Rollenspiele der ersten Stunde. Sag ich mal, ne, erste Stunde ist ja falsch, man wär's ja alt. Nein, also der Vorreiter der Computer-Rollenspiele sozusagen. Dadurch wurden die sehr bekannt, viele haben's gespielt, viele fanden's toll und es hat Rollenspiele an sich populär gemacht.
Und das kommt sozusagen aus dieser Forgotten Realms-Welt heraus, weil's dort eine beschriebene Stadt ist. Genau.
Und weil da Dinge passiert sind, die man da erleben kann. Und auch hier tauchen Charaktere auf, die man aus der Welthintergrund-Beschreibung kennen kann. Ja, und dann hat man halt einen Götterpantheon sich erdacht, dass in Forgotten Realms drauf vorkommt, dass man verehren kann, dass es einem Vorzüge gibt, dass Priester hat, die deren Wunder vollbringen können.
Was meinst du mit Götterpantheon, also sozusagen so ein Satz von Göttern, den es so gibt?
Ja, genau. Also so wie das griechische Götterpantheon, halt in dem Fall ein eigenes. Dazu kann man gleich sagen, dass in D&D 1 noch die Götter frei wählbar waren und sie sogar das griechische Götterpantheon vorgeschlagen haben, das man nehmen könne, um eine gute Vorstellung zu haben, oder skandinavische Götter. Also hat man sich dann jetzt hingesetzt und gesagt, wir machen da was eigenes.
Jetzt sind wir wieder bei den Wikinger.
Ja, doch.
Ich wusste, dass wir da noch hinkommen. Okay, also Götter spielen sich auch generell so eine Rolle. Ist das überhaupt so in Fantasy-Welten Götter?
Ja, also in Fantasy-Welten sind Götter natürlich essentiell. In Science-Fiction- oder Gegenwart-Welten ist das dann nicht mehr ganz so essentiell. Manchmal gibt es sie, manchmal nicht. Häufig höhlt sich der Spieleiter und die Verlage ins Schweigen.
Gibt es ja nicht auch so religiös inspirierte Rollenspiel-Welten?
In Nominee.
Ja, das stimmt, aber In Nominee ist eine Parodie.
Also bei In Nominee spielt man Engel oder Dämonen.
Und verhaut entsprechend die anderen. Bei den Dämonen ist das beste Würfel-Ergebnis mit 3W6.
Eine 666.
Es nimmt sich glücklicherweise selber ganz, ganz doll nicht ernst. Wir verdanken es den lieben Franzosen. Und es macht eine Menge Spaß.
Den Franzosen verdienen wir was genau?
In Nominee.
Ach so. Okay, aber jetzt so Jesus World 3000 oder so.
Das nicht. Ich glaube auch, dass unsere liebe katholische Kirche das ein bisschen vertreffelt.
Stimmt so mein Eindruck, dass diese ganze Rollenspiel, ich weiß nicht, womit hängt denn das so kulturell zusammen? Ich meine, ihr habt ja vorhin euch da schon distanziert, euch da in irgendeine Ecke packen zu lassen. Aber keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, so Kulturen wie, keine Ahnung, so die Gossic-Szene oder so, hat das irgendwie Berührungen?
Es gibt definitiv Systeme, die einzelne Szenen besonders berühren, aber an sich kommen die überall her. Also jede Gesellschaftsschicht, fast jeder Lebensstil, wobei natürlich die Leute, die dann die extremen Juppies sind, nicht so richtig viel Zeit für sowas haben. Ich glaube, es ist eine Frage der Freizeitgestaltung. Und man hat halt Spaß daran, tolle Geschichten zu erleben, zu hören. Ja, zu bespielen eben.
Vielleicht nochmal bei den Forgotten Realms bleiben. Also Städte und Götter, war das schon?
Jaja, Monster sind sehr klassisch festgelegt. Also die Monster tauchen immer wieder auf, egal welches Spiel wir spielen. Häufig heißen sie anders, dann sind es dann halt keine Monster, sondern was weiß ich, Gegenspieler oder Schläger, Superhelden, Superschurken, genau. Und sie tauchen aber dennoch immer irgendwie wieder auf. Man braucht was zum Bekämpfen. Also wir haben ja vorhin schon festgestellt, Kampf ist toll und wichtig und man braucht natürlich was, also hat man auch seine Monster.
Warum ist der Kampf so wichtig?
Nun, persönlich finde ich ihn nicht unbedingt wichtig, aber ich denke, dass das ein grundlegendes Element ist, um Schwierigkeiten zu bewältigen, um Dramatik und Action hineinzubringen.
Und man kann es, wie man es ja auch in Filmen oder so hat, oder in Romanen, man kann sehr gut Punkte drum zentrieren und Aufgaben darauf aufbauen. Also als Spieleiter kann man da direkt sein Setting zum Beispiel nehmen. Es wird auf diesen Kampf hinauslaufen und kann damit meine eigene Runde strukturieren. Also mein eigenes Abenteuer, was ich entwickle, kann ich gut um Kämpfe herum strukturieren. Und die Spieler mögen gerne kämpfen. Viele Leute mögen gerne kämpfen.
Ja, genauso wie viele Leute lieber Action-Filme sehen als irgendwelche romantischen Liebesfilme. Wobei man auch sowas bespielen könnte, aber das ist dann weniger was für 4-5 Leute am Tisch. Die finden das, glaube ich, komisch.
Vielleicht würde man ja mal so ein Hippie-Rollenspiel machen, irgendwie so Flower-Power.
Ja, habe ich schon erlebt, das grandios gescheitert. Es ist nichts passiert, die fanden das alle eher langweilig. Keine Action. Tatsächlich haben die Spieler das so gewollt. Und es gab ein, nennen wir es, Elfen-Hippie-Floppy-Power-Zusammensitzerspiel. Und das war dann denen aber zu langweilig, obwohl sie es eigentlich selber wollten.
Okay, alles klar, dann doch lieber kämpfen.
Doch lieber Action. Es ist doch schon spannender, einen Ork abzuschlachten als irgendwie in einem Blümchen zu riechen.
Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen das Adrenalin, was in dem Moment dann auch einfach durchkommt, oder? Zittert man da so ein bisschen noch irgendwie? Ist spannend, oder? Ich meine, was macht jetzt den Reiz aus für euch?
Also, bei einer richtig... Also bei einer richtig guten Session. Also, meine Erfahrung ist, dass ich gerne und viel spiele, um dann vielleicht die eine richtig gute Session zu finden, wo man dann, wo der Spielleiter wirklich es schafft, Stimmung aufzubauen, dass man dann auch mal in einer gruseligen Szene auch wirklich Gänsehaut bekommt, und sich richtig in seine Figur reinfindet und anfängt. Also, ich spiele eher so die Science-Fiction- oder Near-Future-Rollenspiele, dann irgendwie aufsteht und seine Knarren zieht oder das Sturmgewehr. Und auch dieser Planungsgedanke dann, wenn man irgendwo eindrechen will, so, dass man sich dann vorstellt, das Hochhaus und wie komme ich jetzt in dieses eine gut geschützte Apartment rein und das dann mit meinen Freunden zusammen zu besprechen, zu überlegen, wie man sowas machen kann.
Aber was macht die Session so gut?
Also, erstmal muss ich ja sagen, dass das nicht grundsätzlich am Spieleiter liegt mit der Stimmung. Wenn die Spieler das per tunig hinkriegen, sich da drauf einzulassen, dann geht das natürlich auch nicht. Also, Stimmung entsteht dann, wenn alle begeistert bei der Sache sind und sich das sehr gut vorstellen können, was passiert. Hier ist natürlich wieder doch der Spieleiter gefragt, das gut zu transportieren. Aber wenn man natürlich Clowns und Faxenmacher hat, dann wird da nichts mit der Stimmung. Und dann liegt das auch nicht am Spieleiter. Was ist sonst noch wichtig für die gute Spielrunde, ist, glaube ich, so eine große Bedrohung. Also das Gefühl haben zu müssen, dass man das jetzt unbedingt schaffen muss. Oder beziehungsweise, dass die Figur, die man ja verkörpert, darstellt oder bespielt, dass die das schaffen muss. Sonst, wenn es kein Risiko gibt und kein großes Problem, dann ist da kein Adrenalin, wie du es doch schön gesagt hattest. Und dann gibt es da auch keine große Bewegung. Also dann sitzen sie alle dann doch nur rum. Ich denke, dass dieses Adrenalin, dieses Bewegtsein unbedingt dazugehört, dass das eine große Spielrunde wird. Also eine geistige zweite Gruppe.
Was versetzt einen da irgendwie in Wallung? Also ich meine, man könnte ja hier auch mal so ein... Wie gibt es denn so Realitätsrollenspiele? Man könnte ja hier einfach so Terrorland Deutschland irgendwie. Finde die Bombe irgendwie.
Klar, auf jeden Fall. Das kann man machen. Und das kann die Spieler auch sehr, sehr interessieren.
Dann so Monster, oder so die Schäuble, die so aus ihren Kellern irgendwie herauskommen.
Oder wie auch immer. Sicher kann man machen. Man kann natürlich dieses, man sucht die große Bombe und man gehört zum SEK und versucht das Ganze jetzt zu regulieren. Und dann kann es den Spielern auch sehr, sehr viel Drama bringen, wenn sie vor dieser Bombe endlich stehen, nachdem sie sie lange gesucht haben und sich darauf besonnen haben, was ihre Charaktere dann eigentlich können. Und dann feststellen, ja, wie kriegen wir die jetzt hier weg oder ausgeschaltet oder was machen wir jetzt? Und genau an dem Punkt setzt es natürlich dann ein, dieses große Problem.
Das große Problem.
Genau, ich denke, jede dramatische Runde braucht ein großes Problem.
Und was waren so die besten Sessions? Also ich meine, was war so das große Problem bei euren Sessions, wo es dann wirklich die Gänsehaut eingesetzt hat? So was waren so, könnt ihr euch dann irgendwas erinnern? Oder ist die Erinnerung dann gleich wieder weg?
Kruse und Horrorrunden, ganz fies in irgendwelchen verfallenen Schuppen der Eltern, in denen im Herbst ganz viele Insekten rumkrabbeln und das ist auch noch Thema der Runde.
Ach so, indem man sich sozusagen auch wirklich in einem solchen befindet.
Ja, genau, das ist auf jeden Fall zu nennen.
Wir sind ja wieder bei den Drohungen, also so Set und Setting.
Ja, genau.
Set ist das Spiel und Setting ist, wo man es spielt.
Aber ich hatte zum Beispiel auch schon mal eine sehr gute Runde auf einer Convention, also wo sich viele Rollenspieler treffen, um viele verschiedene Runden zu machen, mitten in der Nacht. Man saß in einem kleinen, gut beleuchteten Hobbykeller. Und der Spieleiter hat es aber trotzdem geschafft, dass einem, als man in dieser Dark-Fantasy-Welt durch das Schloss gegangen ist und auf einmal das Bild einverfolgt hat, und wenn man dann mal geguckt hat, so angefangen hat, dieses Bild zu ritzen, dass es angefangen hat zu bluten, dass einem dann doch auch irgendwie so, was ist denn jetzt los?
Jetzt sind wir natürlich auch wieder beim Horror.
Ja, der Horror ist halt gut für die Gänsehaut und das Adrenalin, aber es gibt auch die Runden, wo man einfach nur Spaß hat. Ich kann mich an eine sehr gute Runde erinnern, wo ich, also die mir als Spieleiter und den Spielern scheinbar auch Spaß gemacht hat, Paranoia, da geht es drum. Das ist ein Setting, so ein bisschen Brave New World. Nee, nicht Brave New World, 1984.
Also was ist Paranoia? Ist das jetzt ein eigenes Rollenspielsystem?
Das ist ein eigenes Rollenspielsystem.
Das ist sowohl ein System als auch Hintergrundwellen natürlich.
Ich hab den Computer. Genau, der Computer, das ist so der große Bruder. Und Verräter gehören exekutiert. Man ist automatisch Verräter, weil man entweder Mutant ist oder zum Beispiel einer politischen Vereinigung angehört. Die Spieler sind von vornherein Mutanten, die einer politischen Vereinigung angehören und alle gut bewaffnet sind.
Und sie haben den Auftrag, Verräter zu suchen und zu eliminieren. Selbstterminierung funktioniert, ist aber natürlich blöd.
Alle sind verdächtig.
Genau, und jeder Spieler hat sechs Leben in diesem Spiel.
Das heißt, man spielt auch gegeneinander?
Nur bei Paranoia spielt man gegeneinander, in der Regel spielt man miteinander. Und bei Paranoia hat man so eine Mischung aus gegeneinander und miteinander spielen.
Man weiß nicht so recht, wie man vertrauen darf.
Man hat keine Beweise.
Genau, und diese Runde war unwahrscheinlich lustig. Und die Spieler haben es noch nicht mal bis zum Anfang geschafft, von dem, was sie tun sollten, bis alle sechs Klone bei allen Spielern bis auf einen einzigen Tod waren. Die Spieler haben es geschafft, sich über vier Stunden ohne überhaupt in dieses Abenteuer reinzukommen, ständig gegenseitig wegzuprezeln.
Und hatten scheinbar viel Spaß dabei.
Genau, hatten Riesenspaß dabei.
Gibt es da auch Hacker bei Paranoia?
Na klar, aber...
Die haben die Stufe Ultraviolett. Das ist die höchste Sicherheitsstufe. Das sind die Computer-Administratoren.
Ah, genau. Und wer Hacking-Fähigkeiten besitzt, oder Computer-Empathie, der ist automatisch verdächtig.
Ah, na ja, da ist auch was Wahres dran. Alle verdächtig.
Genau.
Paranoia, ist das jetzt so ein gängiges Show, oder ist das so ein Solitär innerhalb dieser Systeme?
Das ist ein Spaß-Rollenspiel. Spaß-Rollenspiele sind kein... Die werden ab und zu mal ausgepackt. Aber das ist jetzt nichts, was man permanent und unentwegt spielt.
Weil am Ende braucht man dann doch wieder seine Helden und seine Fantasy-Welten.
Na, es lutscht sich sehr aus, wie mit einer Komödie im Fernsehen. Wenn man die dreimal sieht, ist sie auch nicht mehr lustig. Vielleicht doch, aber in dem Fall...
Bis auf die einigen wenigen, ja, die man sich die ganze Zeit anschauen kann.
Genau.
Man kann Paranoia so wenig erreichen, weil die Chance, dass der Charakter noch steht am Schluss von einem Abenteuer, ist sehr gering. Sich zu jeder Sitzung neuen Charakter zu bauen, ist auch nicht so der Bringer.
Was du von Paranoia erzählst, das erinnert mich ein bisschen an das Illuminati-Brettspiel.
Das Kartenspiel?
Ja, das Brettspiel, wo man mit Verschwörungen arbeitet. Der Steve Jackson, der das macht, ist ja auch in dieser Rollenspiel-Szene unterwegs.
Ja klar, ganz groß sogar.
Womit?
Der macht ganz schön viel. Zum einen hat er ein ganzes Regelset, sozusagen seinen Spielern zukommen lassen, bzw. seine Firma hat das getan. Dort haben sie versucht, alles unter einen Hut zu bringen. Das System, von dem ich spreche, heißt GURPS. Dieses GURPS kommt leider daher, dass sie fanden, keinen richtigen Namen haben zu müssen und sich auf dieses generisch- universelle Rollenspielsystem berufen.
Also GURPS heißt Generic Universal Role-Playing System.
Genau. Das hat sich einfach irgendwie so eingeschliffen. Sind es jetzt auch bei der fünften Edition inzwischen schon. Das heißt, da geht es voran.
Und da brauchst du ganz schön große Regalbretter, um die ganzen Weltenbeschreibungen unterzubringen. Also die haben halt ein Regelsystem und unendlich viele Welten.
Genau. Also sie unterstützen richtig viele Welten. Das ist so deren Ziel. Teilweise borken sie sich Welten von anderen Spielen, aber sie denken sich sehr, sehr viel auch selber aus. Sie bringen alle Settings, die man sich wünschen kann, auf den Markt und da haben das mal getan. Warten jetzt darauf, dass sie das weiter tun.
Ja, genau. Und manchmal führt es auch dazu, dass man vom Secret Service auseinandergenommen wird. Also Cyberpunk, sie haben das Rollenspiel, sie haben eine Welt zum Genre Cyberpunk rausgebracht. Und sie sind damals bei dieser, was war das, Operation Phoenix oder wie das hieß, Anfang der 90er mit dem Cult of the Dead Cow, als es da diese Cyber Wars in den USA gab, wo sich der Secret Service mit dem bösen Hackern angelegt hat, gab es halt irgendwie einen, der halt Ahnung von der Szene und der Matthäer hatte und der hat dieses Cyberpunk-Regelwerk geschrieben. Und irgendwie ist dann der Secret Service auf Steve Jackson Games gekommen und hat dieses Cyberpunk-Regelwerk gefunden und dachte, das ist jetzt ein Buch für Computerverbrechen und hat daraufhin den kompletten Verlag einmal auseinandergenommen. So eine Anleitung fürs Hacking.
Und das Buch dann korrigiert zurückgegeben.
Warte mal, wer hat das korrigiert zurückgegeben?
Der Secret Service hat das dann... Ernsthaft? Ja, ja, ernsthaft. Also es wurden Seiten entfernt.
Ah, ach so, so korrigiert. Ach so, die hatten sozusagen in ihrem Zahlerbandgame...
Nein, die haben nicht den Nachlesetest darauf angewandt und gesagt, oh, hier sind aber noch Fehler. Nein, sie haben natürlich gesagt, das darf so nicht an die Öffentlichkeit.
Ach, das Regelwerk war sozusagen wahr.
Sagen wir, es war glaubwürdig.
Zu glaubwürdig für den Secret Service sozusagen.
Genau.
So nach dem Motto, das ist eine Information, die darf nicht jetzt hier in die Info passieren.
Wobei man natürlich sagen kann, dass das nicht immer nur so passiert, dass der Secret Service die Verlage stürmt und sagt, so geht es nicht, Cyberpunk als solches, also jetzt nicht von GURPS, sondern eigens selbst nochmal von einem, mir jetzt gerade unbekannten Verlag.
Talsorian Games war das.
Super, der Mann weiß, was er hat seine Hausaufgaben gemacht. Wie heißt das?
Talsorian Games, hießen die damals, 90er Jahre. Talsorian Games.
Genau, die haben das halt rausgemacht und die haben sogar ihrerseits mit dem FBI stark zusammengearbeitet, um ein glaubwürdiges und realistisches Schadenssystem einzubauen und deren verwendete Schusswaffen sehr realistisch innerhalb des Systems zu halten. Also auch hier wieder kämpfen ist wichtig. Wobei das bei Cyberpunk natürlich tatsächlich, also wenn man sich die ganzen Cyberpunk-Filme anguckt, ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Bestandteil ist, dass gekämpft wird gegen die Regierung, gegen die Megakonzerne. Kämpfen, kämpfen, kämpfen.
Also man ist immer schon so ein bisschen bei den Guten, ja?
Ja, tendenziell schon. Nicht grundsätzlich, nicht grundsätzlich. Manche Spieler brechen halt in Hochhäuser ein, aber tendenziell ist man schon eigentlich so, ja, auf der guten Seite.
Das heißt, diese Analogie zu Filmen und zu Action-Spielen, die kommt ja hier laufend. Also kann man so sagen, dass so ein bisschen Rollenspiel auch so das Hollywood zum selber machen ist, dass man sich sozusagen einfach so seine Filme im Kopf einfach interaktiv selber ablaufen lässt und dabei irgendwie Spaß hat?
Ja, definitiv. Ich saß auch schon im Film und dachte mir, das will ich nachspielen. Genau das will ich machen.
Aber da hast du es ja schon gesehen. Ich meine, das ist ja irgendwie...
Ja, aber dass man so dieses Setting hat und diese Charaktere, weil die einfach cool dargestellt sind und weil die coole Aktionen machen.
Was heißt, man bricht sich dann quasi seine Welt heraus?
Ja, genau.
Das, was in einem Film alles zusammenkommt, sozusagen die Welt, die Charaktere und dann das damit assoziierte Regelsystem, was die sozusagen können.
Oder man transponiert es einfach auf ein System, was man eh schon spielt. Also jetzt zum Beispiel bei Action-Filmen eignen sich eben sowas wie Cyberpunk-Systeme oder also so Near-Future-Systeme oder moderne, also die halt so moderne Welten eh schon beschreiben und dann kann man das relativ gut darauf umbrechen.
Welcher Film war das?
Zum Beispiel jetzt kürzlich The Losers. Da geht es um ein fünfköpfiges Militärteam, die gelingt werden und sich dann finster mit viel Schusswaffengewalt rächen.
Ja und natürlich Cleverness und also es kommen die klassischen wichtigen Elemente vor. Also das heißt Schockentum, irgendwie ein bisschen Hacking, ein bisschen Unauffälligkeit. Es gibt da einen unwahrscheinlich, ja wie soll ich sagen, draufgängerischen Anführer der ganzen Geschichte. Also das A-Team in Future und besser, würde ich sagen.
Und sehr lustige Charakterinteraktion und...
Er ist ja auch so charakterisch.
Ja, genau. Das A-Team ist natürlich auch quasi ein Denkbeispiel für Rollenspiele. Also man hat halt Individualisten, die sich zusammentun und Dinge tun, meistens die Welt retten oder sowas.
Und gibt es denn dann auch so Rollenspiele, die dann auch ganz konkret mit so Filmen zusammenhängen? Also kommen dann dann so die Filmproduzenten dann so selber schon auf die Idee, so wie sie sich da Computerspiele dafür bauen, dass man dann eben auch noch gleich so ein Rollenspielset rausbringt?
Ja, also Star Wars ist das populärste.
Ah, Star Wars gibt es als Rollenspiel.
Star Wars gibt es mit zwei verschiedenen Regelsystemen als Rollenspiel, was auch das komplette Star Wars Universum glaube ich abbildet, aber da weißt du mehr.
Genau, also Western Games hat damals ein Rollenspielsystem auf den Markt gestellt, das sehr, sehr detailliert auf Star Wars eingegangen ist und das den ohnehin schon existierenden Rollenspielern angeboten hat, die das dann auch sehr gerne genutzt haben. Inzwischen ist ja alles so ein bisschen bei D&D und seinem System gelandet und entsprechend gibt es da inzwischen auch ein Star Wars Szenario.
Was meinst du, dass ist alles bei denen gelandet?
Na, D&D hat ein System auf den Markt gestellt, das W20-System, also das D20-System, bei dem sie alles auf eine bestimmte...
D20?
D20, genau. Also W20 als deutsches Pendant. Es geht darum, mit einem 20-Seiter alle möglichen Proben, außer unbedingt Schaden, auszuwürfeln.
Ach so, Würfel, Dice, W, D, A, P, A, S, klar, verstehe.
Alles auszuwürfeln und deswegen das D20-System. Und dieses D20-System, das war auf einmal ganz populär und alle möglichen Systeme haben versucht, da so ein bisschen aufzuspringen und ihr System als D20 angeboten. Natürlich kann man nicht jedes System, jedes Szenario mit jedem System gleich gut bespielen. Das heißt, einige Systeme, die sehr auf Charakterentwicklung basieren, lassen sich damit spielen. Andere Systeme, wo es dann doch eher um tiefgründigere Sachen geht, Horror zum Beispiel, lassen sich damit nicht so gut spielen. Und das haben sie dann auch gemerkt, das bleiben lassen. Nur eben Star Wars hat gesagt, es ist prima für uns, das wollen wir und haben da in mehreren Auflagen...
Okay, also diese ganze Rollenspielwelt, das ist auch so ein bisschen wie in der Betriebssystemlandschaft. Es gibt da verschiedene OS- und Laufzeitumgebungen, eben diese Spielsysteme, die dann so ganz konkret sagen, diese Würfel und so wird hier irgendwie gekämpft und so wird hier miteinander, was weiß ich, Zufallshandel betrieben. Und dann gibt es sozusagen die eigentlichen Settings, die Welten, die das Ganze dann so ausklammbüsern, das GUI quasi, wo man dann irgendwie seine Spiele dann konkret drin landen kann. Und Star Wars ist dann aber nicht jetzt, das kam aber nicht von George Lucas sozusagen, sondern es waren dann so andere, die das genommen haben.
Natürlich hat es das große Okay des George Lucas bekommen, das heißt, es gab rechte Geschichten, das heißt, es gibt auch immer nur einen Anbieter gleichzeitig auf dem Markt, der Star Wars rausbringen darf.
Sie haben das sozusagen entwickelt, sind dann zu George Lucas gelatscht und haben gesagt, hier, guck mal.
Genau, genau. Und da wurde dann viel von deren Autoren und so noch dazugetan. Also es gibt ja viele Romanautoren und so, die sich mit hingesetzt haben und gesagt haben, ja, Quatsch-Charakter, Systementwicklung, ganz wichtig, hier und da und guck mal.
Das heißt, das ist dann sozusagen auch Teil der Merchandising-Welt.
Na klar, auf jeden Fall.
Die müssen da Lizenzen zahlen. Und wenn man dann sozusagen das Box-Set da kauft, dann geht dann halt wieder auch ein bisschen was dahin. Aber es hat natürlich auch den Vorteil, dass das natürlich Welten sind, in denen sich viele Leute schon mal ganz gut auskennen, beziehungsweise wo sie dann schon als kleines Kind sich hineingefühlt haben und von daher auch so eine eigene Begeisterung mit sich bringen, oder?
Oder man will es halt selber also Fernsehen. Es gibt auch das Buffy the Vampire Slayer Rollenspiel. Und da spielt man halt quasi eine Gruppe mit einem Hunter und irgendwie seinen Sidekicks.
Genau.
Oder Ghostbusters.
Die beliebteste Klasse ist irgendwie der Loser.
Den Sender gespielt hat in der Fernsehserie.
Genau. Der, der nichts kann, dem aber auch nie was passiert.
Hab ich, glaube ich, nie gesehen. So eine amerikanische Fernsehserie, ja.
In den 90ern mit Sarah Michelle Geller.
Ich guck zu wenig Fernsehen.
Ach, das ist nicht schlimm.
Naja, ich komm komplett raus hier. War das jetzt eher lustig oder war das eher so horrorig?
Das ist so eine Mischung.
Also tatsächlich hat es versucht, diesen Fernsehstil beizubehalten. Also das heißt, so ein bisschen Seriencharakter zu behalten und den Daily-Horror anzubieten, um halt irgendwie einem Sendekarakter in Kurzepisoden das Ganze bespielen zu können. Und darauf waren die Charaktere zugeschnitten.
Und funktioniert das dann auch? Ich meine, gibt es das nur oder sind das dann auch wirklich populäre Auskopplungen? Funktioniert das so, wie Computerspiele zum Filmen funktionieren?
Nee, ganz ehrlich, nein. Also die meisten Film- und Fernsehrollenspiele sind nur, ja, Merchandise und Versuche, so was ein bisschen populärer noch zu machen. Aber häufig klappt das nicht.
Warum funktioniert das nicht?
Na, weil die Spieler keine Lust haben, in einer Serie gefangen zu sein, in einem Film. Wollen viel Eigenes machen. Ich meine, wie spannend ist das denn, bei Star Wars mitzuspielen, wenn du nicht selber, weiß ich nicht, Obi-Wan bist oder so? Na, der Charakter Obi-Wan wäre ja zu sehr vorgegeben, als dass man denen einen Spieler geben möchte. Es wäre dann so, ja, wir erleben heute mal die Zerstörung des ersten Todessterns aus der Sicht von Darth Vader, der alles anders macht. Und deswegen kommt es nicht dazu. Also das will man halt nicht. Man will halt nicht die Filme oder die Serien neu aufwenden.
Man ist ja auch nicht Darth Vader, sondern man ist so Black-Hybrid-Mail-Machine.
Man spielt oftmals jemanden, der zwar in derselben Welt umherläuft und im Optimalfall. Also es gibt auch zum Beispiel das Mittelerderollenspiel, was auf Tolkien dann wirklich, also was in der Welt von Herr der Ringe spielt. Und da kann man dann quasi die Charaktere aus den Büchern treffen. Das geht rein theoretisch, aber man bespielt sie nicht. Man ist halt irgendwer da drin.
Das geht auch bei Star Wars, aber wer will schon Darth Vader treffen?
Das heißt, man ist eigentlich eher so ein weißer Roboter oder irgendwie so ein Sandmann.
Genau, aber man kann sich das ja frei aussuchen. Genau, man kann sich das ja frei aussuchen, aber man ist tendenziell eher ein kleines Licht, das dann dadurch das riesige Universum vegetiert.
Verstehe. Das heißt, ihr meint, das funktioniert gar nicht?
Begrenzt, natürlich. Es gibt viele Leute, die eine Menge Spaß damit haben. Aber ich bezweifle, dass sie es permanent, also dass sie permanent dieses Spiel spielen. Und dann ist es natürlich sehr thematisiert. Das heißt, Buffy wird natürlich nur von Leuten angeguckt, die auch Buffy mögen. Und von den Leuten, die Buffy mögen, spielen das vielleicht 10% und dann auch nur einmal. Also nicht einmal als Sitzung, sondern nur einmal. Und dann haben sie alle genug gespielt. Dann wollen sie wieder was anderes.
Aber gibt es nicht vielleicht noch so Filme, die so von ihrem Setting her genug hergeben, dass man da sich so, ich meine, was ist zum Beispiel mit Matrix?
Wird ironischerweise gar nicht unterstützt. Man kann natürlich Systeme benutzen, die ihrerseits so eine Hintergrundwelt ermöglichen. Aber es gab nie ein Matrix.
Es gab mal ein Black-Rollenspiel. Aber das war auch irgendwie nur so ein dünnes Buch, was nicht wirklich gut ausgearbeitet war zum Beispiel.
Das gab es auch nicht wirklich lange. Aber zum Beispiel Star Trek. Es gibt ja eine sehr große Trackey-Community. Und entsprechend gibt es da auch einen guten Absatz für Rollenspiele. Und das wird natürlich auch gespielt. Es gibt Fans davon. Aber es schafft es dennoch nicht zu den großen Systemen, wie nun mal D&D 1 ist. Oder halt DSA, Shadowrun. Nein. Shadowrun ist ein Nahezukunftsspiel, in dem man tatsächlich in verbrecherischer Absicht Aufträge erledigt, in Hochhäuser, Entbrechen.
Also, Shadowrun ist quasi, wir nehmen Cyberpunk und wir nehmen Fantasy und werfen beides zusammen. Ich spiele zwischen 2055 und 2070 irgendwas und habe aber nicht nur den Typen, der halt durch die Gegend rennt, mit seinen Waffen und Cyberware, also kybernetischen Verbesserungen, sondern ich hab da auch den Magier drin und es gibt Elfe und Elfen und Orks und Trolle und Drachen und...
Aber nichts ist automatisch böse, das muss man hier bei berücksichtigen.
Genau.
In vielen Systemen ist ja eine Klassifizierung vorgenommen worden, das heißt Orks, Trolle gleich böse, Drachen gleich meistens böse und Menschen und Elfen gleich gut und hier ist es halt, alle sind, was sie sind. Also so schlecht, wie ein Mensch nun mal normalerweise ist.
Viele Schattierungen von Schwarz.
Aber alle sind irgendwie böse.
Naja, es ist die echte Welt. Also, naja, die echte. Man versucht sich an dem zu orientieren, was es gibt. Und das ganz, ganz böse sind natürlich, Cyberpunk gemäß die großen bösen Konzerne. Und das nicht ganz so ganz, ganz böse sind dann die Spieler.
Ja, Drachen sind auch nicht unbedingt böse. Drachen sind dann eher so was wie die Illuminaten.
Sind der Drachen sonst immer böse?
Drachen sind in der Regel böse.
Aber in den Filmen, da fliegt man auch mal.
Ja, es gibt natürlich dann bei D&D gibt's die klassischen, die metallenden Drachen, die halt alle böse sind. Nee, die alle gut sind. Und die farblichen Drachen, die sind alle böse. Und dann gibt's da ein bisschen Clinch und die Charaktere mitten drin. Aber viele Systeme gehen natürlich davon aus, dass der Drache der große Gegner ist. Und demzufolge, Gegner, gleich böse, gleich...
.wischt ihr einfache Welt.
Und in Shadowrun ist es halt der Strippenzieher. Im Hintergrund. Den man auch nicht unbedingt begegnen will. Aber das ist dann so...
Und ist Shadowrun ein populäres Spiel?
Ja. Das hält sich jetzt schon seit über 20 Jahren. Gab's zwar immer mal wieder... Also ist Anfang der 90er aufgekommen. Gibt's jetzt auch in der vierten, also... Vierte Edition mit Patch. Inzwischen patcht man Rollenspiele eher, als dass man sie in neuen Editionen rausbringt.
Ach echt? Haben die auch Versionsnummern?
Jaja, 4.01d in unserem Fall, Deutschland. Und da sind dann tatsächlich so Eraten aufgenommen.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt auf andere Rollenspieler trifft, dann muss man dann erst mal so seine Versionen abgleichen.
Tatsächlich, ja. Es gibt auch viele, die dann sagen, ne, der neueste Patch gefällt mir nicht, das ist Mist, ich will das alte behalten.
Das ist doch was für Nerds.
Also, ich meine, man muss schon einen gewissen Hang haben zu Systemen und Regelwerken, oder?
Aber sind wir nicht alle Nerds? Ich meine, man guckt mal in Richtung Fußballfans. Ich meine, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die mir sagen können, wer welche Nummer auf dem Platz hat. Na ja, ich denke, Nerd sein wäre ja dann... Man kennt sich mit seinem Hobby aus. In dem Fall sind wir alle Nerds in irgendeiner Hinsicht. Und wenn wir kleine Porzellanpüppchen sammeln und wissen, von wann...
Aber streitet man sich dann auch in demselben Maße darüber, ob das jetzt ein Foul war oder nicht?
Ja, eindeutig. Spieler-Spielleiter-Regeldiskussion gehören zum Rollenspiel dazu wie Monster schlagen. Also, natürlich sind sie nicht unbedingt erwünscht.
Wenn die dann auch ausgewirbelt...
Das wird dann kurzerhand diskutiert. Eine Stunde, zwei oder so.
Und wie man denn diese Regel interpretiert, oder ob nicht der dritte Absatz von Seite 276 aus dem Buch, das nicht anders macht als...
Wir haben Nerds. Wir nennen sie Regelanwälte. Das sind die, die sich so ein Regelwerk durchlesen und quasi paragrafengetreu abarbeiten können. Und im Zweifelsfall dann ganz, ganz groß erzählen, dass es doch alles anders ist und der Spieleiter Unrecht hat. Was natürlich auch wieder so ein Knackpunkt ist. Denn wenn der Erzähler Unrecht hat, dann funktioniert die Geschichte nicht. Also hat der Spieleiter meistens Recht.
Und dann verweist man auf die goldene Regel, die eigentlich in jedem Regelsystem drin steht. Was der Spieleiter sagt, hat der Spieleiter Recht.
Genau.
Der Schiri hat sozusagen Recht und Wild, aber Fußball.
Ja, genau. Und da sind wir dann wieder bei der Fußballparallele. Und dann sind wir Nerds. Ja, genau.
Weil ich glaube, im Fußballstadion hat so der gemeine Fan dann doch relativ wenig Einfluss auf das Spielgeschehen. Oder habt ihr dann auch so Fans, die sozusagen um... Man ist ja eigentlich immer unter sich. Also, ich meine, alle, die im Raum sind, spielen auch mit. Oder gibt es dann irgendwie auch Zuschauer?
Manchmal. Also, manchmal gibt es Leute, die sagen, ich würde mir das gern angucken. Oder wenn man auf Conventions spielt, die dann einfach von mal angelaufen kommen und gucken, was läuft gerade bei euch ab. Und dann hat man natürlich auch Zuschauer. Und das ist häufig genug für diese Zuschauer auch spannend.
Wie muss man sich denn diese Conventions vorstellen?
Jeder anderen hat auch. Also, nehmen wir zum Beispiel... Ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon mal auf einer Convention... Nehmen wir eine große Convention für Computertechnik. Und dann gibt es halt die Sachen, wo sie alle hinrennen, was sie gucken wollen, die Gratisproben, die sie abgreifen wollen. Und da, wo sie was zu sagen haben.
Da setzt man jetzt nichts voraus. Also, ich meine, was muss ich mir unter einer Convention vorstellen? Wer geht da hin?
Nach Fans, natürlich.
Aber ist das jetzt sozusagen nur für Dungeons & Dragons, Version 4.32, Patch Level 27 oder?
Nein, tatsächlich ist es natürlich offen. Jeder versucht, sein Interessensgebiet zu vertreten. Oder zu besuchen auf dieser Convention.
Das heißt, es sind einfach Rollenspieler-Conventions, wo sozusagen alle von allen Systemen und allen Versionen und Patch Level nach hinkommen können.
Manchmal nicht, aber häufig eigentlich schon. Also, manchmal gibt es halt Restriktionen. Oder es gibt Themen.
Gibt es auch etablierte Namen? Gibt es etablierte Conventions, wo sie alle hingehen?
In den USA der GenCon.
Wir haben ja auch in Deutschland. Wir haben die RPC und wir haben den NordCon. Da rennen sie alle hin. Den FeenCon, der ist nicht in Deutschland, aber ich glaube, der war in den Niederlanden. Auf jeden Fall kann man da ganz gut hinkommen. Es ist ein ganz großes Ding. Gehen sie auch immer alle hin. Die Spielemesse in Essen ist auch ein ganz großer Anlaufpunkt für Rollenspieler. Also insofern gibt es richtig, richtig große. Es gibt in Berlin aktuell zwei kleine. Also Berlin ist ja für uns beide wichtig. Da sitzen wir ja rum, da machen wir viel. Und, ähm, ja, also, es gibt überall. Was, wenn man da macht? Man trifft sich mit Gleichgesinnten. Okay, das klingt jetzt doof. Sagen wir, man trifft sich mit Fans. Und, ähm, von einem. Also man unterhält sich da natürlich weitestgehend mit den Leuten, die, äh, Ja, mit meinen Fans.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es ja Rollenspieler, die jetzt besonders bekannt sind oder so, weil sie irgendwie öffentlich spielen oder so.
Na, es gibt dann, na, eher nicht. Also zum Beispiel, früher konnte man auf den größeren Conventions in den USA, Gary Gygax, konnte man direkt bei ihm spielen. Der hat der Spielrunden angeboten selber. Also der Urvater.
Was es übrigens immer noch teilweise gibt, ne?
Und dann gibt es natürlich, ähm, wenn man, man kann Autoren zum Beispiel treffen, von den Redaktionen. Und kann dann direkt mit denen, also, dass die den Spieleiter machen. Oder es gibt zum Beispiel, wenn man, es gibt auch Spieler, die irgendwie, die man in der Szene quasi, von denen man schon mal gehört hat, und dass man mit denen mal spielen will, weil man gehört hat, dass die halt irgendwie besonders lustig sind, oder besonders gute Spiele machen, oder besondere Spieleiter, die halt einen Ruf haben.
Okay, also gibt's schon auch, aber steht jetzt nicht so im Mittelpunkt. Gibt jetzt nicht so ein Kult.
Nee, Kult gibt's nicht, aber tatsächlich kann man Leute treffen, die vom Verlagswesen her sehr, sehr bekannt sind, oder für fertige Abenteuer bekannt sind. Kommen teilweise zu solchen Conventions, und dann kann man bei denen spielen, oder man kann sich anhören, was die so zu erzählen haben. In Workshops, das ist aktuell ein bisschen untergegangen, gab's aber zumindest in den letzten Jahren immer mal wieder.
Aber das frisst doch enorm viel Zeit. Ich meine, so eine Session, ich meine, wie lange sitzt man so üblicherweise zusammen für so ein Game?
Ähm, also ich versuch's inzwischen bei meinen eigenen Runden auf Convention-Länge zu reduzieren. Das sind 4 bis 6 Stunden. Das ist mal so ein... Also ich hab auch schon Sessions gehabt, wo ich mich um 8 mit den Leuten getroffen hab und um 6, 7 Uhr morgens bin ich nach Hause gefahren.
Das ist ja länger als der durchschnittliche überlange Podcast.
Es ist natürlich bei den zusammenspielenden Gruppen ganz denen zuzuschreiben, wie lange gespielt wird. Meistens haben die Leute nur begrenzt Zeit. Aber Schüler, Studenten oder Leute mit einem sehr freigestalteten Job haben manchmal die Möglichkeit sehr lange und sehr ausgiebig zu spielen. Und da sind dann 10, 12, 14 Stunden keine Seltenheit. Manchmal wird sowas unterbrochen und dann vorgespielt.
Aber wonach richtet sich dann, wie lange es wirklich dauert? Ist das sozusagen die Komplexität der Welt, der Spielverlauf, bis man wirklich zum Ende ist? Oder ist das einfach nur, weil man sich die ganze Zeit darüber unterhält, wie die Regeln jetzt genau zu interpretieren sind?
Also es richtet sich nach dem Abenteuer, was der Spieleiter entworfen hat. Und wie sehr die Spieler sich auch auf den Spieleiter quasi zukommen. Ob sie jetzt ihr eigenes Ding machen wollen, so ein bisschen Characterplay. Also ich gehe einkaufen und verbringe jetzt erstmal zwei Stunden damit im Spiel zu erforschen, was dann jetzt irgendwie das beste Schwert ist, was ich gerade auf dem Markt kriegen kann.
Also Shopping.
Ja genau, das kann man machen. Das kann natürlich alles in die Länge ziehen. Wenn die Spieler drauf stehen, kann man das natürlich machen. Und dann kommt das natürlich, kann man Abenteuer auch extrem lang ziehen als Spieleiter. Also ich kann ja ganze Kampagnen bauen mit vielen Abenteuern und kann dann Cliffhanger einbauen. Ich habe zum Beispiel eine meiner letzten Runden, die musste man dann auf zwei Abende verteilen, weil die Spieler es gerade mal geschafft haben, am ersten Abend die Planungsphase durchzumachen. Also sie hatten halt einen bestimmten Auftrag in der Science-Fiction-Welt, hatten einen bestimmten Auftrag etwas zu tun und haben es in der ersten Runde innerhalb von sechs Stunden oder so geschafft, gerade mal die Planungsphase durchzuziehen. Und dann war das halt, dann hätte man jetzt weiterspielen können oder man sagt halt Cut, Cliffhanger, wir machen jetzt beim nächsten Mal weiter. Und dann guckt man halt, dass man aber diesen Auftrag auch wieder auf eine erträgliche Länge langzieht als Spielleiter. Also dass das dann halt nicht in zwanzig Minuten erledigt ist, sondern irgendwie dann auch wieder vier Stunden braucht. Dann kann man ja gegebenenfalls dynamisch noch hinten was dranhängen, dass irgendwie sie nochmal irgendwie betrogen werden oder die Flucht sich als schwerer herausstellt, als sie dachten und indem man ihnen einfach noch mal ein paar Feine entgegenwirft. Und zum Beispiel in dem Moment, wo es zum Kampf kommt, kann das auch alles auf einmal ausarten, weil Kämpfe irgendwie 20 Sekunden im Spielkampf, das kann eine Stunde mit Würfelei zu tun haben und Beschreibungen, wie man denn am besten das jetzt macht.
Also Conventionlänge sagst du, ist vier bis sechs Stunden. Das heißt auf diesen Conventions, wie lange dauern die denn?
Mehrere Tage.
Das heißt, da verbringen die Leute wirklich einen Großteil einfach nur mit dem Spielen?
Leute treffen, neue Spiele kennenlernen. Also, weil das ist der optimale Ort, um mal ein anderes System reinzuschnuppern, weil ich habe da Spielleiter, die Runden anbieten mit dem System. Und damit kann ich mir auch mal ein Spiel angucken. Dann gibt's natürlich auf den größeren Conventions gibt's dann auch Angebot von, dass die Verlage sich ausstellen und ich gegebenenfalls auch Bücher kriege, die es jetzt noch gar nicht im Handel gibt, weil die halt Form rausbringen, also wie messemäßig halt. Ja und mit Leuten unterhalten. Also Leute treffen, spielen, shoppen.
Ist ja schon häufig gefallen, schon im Einstieg auch. Natürlich klar, Tolkien, der da so mit seinen Werken einiges ausgelöst hat, aber ihr habt zwischendurch auch immer wieder so erwähnt, es gibt da ja dann auch so Romane und so. Also ich meine, inwiefern begleitet denn jetzt so die ganze Fiction-Literatur, dieses Rollenspiel-Genre und inwiefern beeinflusst sich das? Was ist da von was, ein Spin-off?
Also zum Beispiel für Shadowrun gibt es eine Riesen-Roman-Reihe. Also ich persönlich habe jetzt irgendwie über 30 gelesen, es gibt weitaus mehr inzwischen. Und die beschreiben dann oftmals den Metaplot. Also ich habe so diese Welt und die Weltbeschreibung wird teilweise über die Bücher, über die Regelwerke, die verkauft werden, weitergetrieben. Also die Geschichte, die passiert. Und gleichzeitig gibt es dann Romane, die gezielt Ereignisse daran beschreiben. Und dann kann ich halt diesen Metaplot, der halt diese komplette Welt umgibt, kann mit diesen Romanen weitergeführt werden. Das ist oftmals bei anderen Systemen auch so. Und dann kann ich natürlich auch Romane direkt auf dieser Welt basieren, weil ich habe alles, um meinen Charakter auszubauen und zu sagen, also als Roman-Autor hat man da ja wunderbare Werkzeuge, um Charaktere zu bauen und Grundlagen zu schaffen. Und hat ja schon zumindest ein Setting vorgegeben und muss nicht mal alles von vorne rein machen. Und da sind dann auch zum Beispiel Shadowrun, wurde in Deutschland von Heine, was ja auch ein cooles Raffalag ist, rausgegeben.
Und sind denn diese Romane irgendwie jetzt anders als andere Romane? Ist das jetzt irgendwas?
Sie sind halt in dieser Welt. In meiner Erfahrung sind sie in der Regel nicht ganz so gut, außer man...
Warum liest du dann 30 Stück davon?
Damals fand ich sie gut und sie haben äußerst gut die Welt beschrieben und ich wusste, was daran vorgeht und es hat mich einfach interessiert, was in dieser Welt. Also es ist halt so mein Stammensystem, es ist Shadowrun und ich wusste dann, wie es halt in dieser Welt weitergeht. Okay.
Also dazu sollte man vielleicht sagen, dass gerade bei Shadowrun am Anfang Romane von den Machern quasi gefordert wurden, es wurden Autoren dafür angestellt, denen gesagt wurde, so und so wollen wir das haben und dann geschah es, dass plötzlich Fans anfingen, Romane zu schreiben und gesagt haben, können wir da das Shadowrun-Label drauf bekommen und dadurch plötzlich Kleinautoren, die geschrieben haben und das natürlich dann sich auch in der Qualität des Romans teilweise wiege gespiegelte. Manchmal waren die Charaktere, die drin vorkamen, viel lebendige, ich sag mal, weil es echte Charaktere waren, also Spielercharaktere, die benutzt wurden, womit das Erlebte tatsächlich in einem Roman wiedergegeben werden konnte.
Das heißt, die haben sozusagen aus ihren Sessions dann wiederum Romane gemacht?
Genau, oder zumindestens dran angelehnt, drauf aufgebaut. inzwischen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Verlag überhaupt noch Leute direkt anstellt dafür. Ich glaube, das ist alles inzwischen sehr durch Fans durchwachsen. Es gibt natürlich doch, die Whiskids haben einige Autoren nochmal angestellt, aber es gibt da hauptsächlich nur noch Fanfiction.
Aber es gibt zu vielen Rollen, also zu den größeren Rollenspielen gibt es eigentlich auch oftmals Romanreihen. Ich denke mal, das hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass man damit halt zusätzlich Geld auch machen kann. Also von Verlagssicht aus, weil das sind Fans, die wollen dann auch in den Welten Geschichten lesen.
Und sehen, was sie machen können.
Einfach als Inspiration sozusagen. Aber eben auch als einfacher Einstieg, um überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen zu schnallen, was es eigentlich heißt, sich in einer Welt zu bewegen, was es überhaupt bedeutet, was diese Welt sozusagen versucht abzustecken.
Ja, das macht es auf jeden Fall einfacher. Also, wenn man in ein neues System einsteigt und da sind zum Beispiel keine Kurzgeschichten oder so ein Grundregelwerk drin, wird es gleich schwerer, in diese Welten einzusteigen.
hängt denn das jetzt mit der ganzen Computer-Welt zusammen? Du hast ja schon gesagt, es gibt hier Never Winter Nights so als Rollen, Computer-Rollenspiel. Was für also wie ist denn diese Rollenspiel-Welt so mit den Computern in Verbindung? Was gibt es da?
Na, in dem Augenblick, wo die Rollenspiele einer ernstzunehmenden Personengröße darstellten, hat man sich natürlich gesagt, okay, wie können wir die dazu bringen, noch mehr Geld auszugeben? Und hat sich gedacht, na, machen wir ein paar Computerspiele. Computer sind sowieso gerade modern und ganz toll. Und anders herum konnte man sich ein Spiel ausdenken, für das man relativ Hintergrundmaterial zusammen sammeln konnte. Man hat sich an den Rollenspielen orientiert.
Also dann wiederum an den Romanen bzw. an den Geschichten, die mit den Spielen sowieso schon kamen.
Ja, genau. Und sogar an den Systemen. Also Neverwinter Nights zum Beispiel verwendet ja das Dungeons & Dragons-System und zwar fast 1 zu 1. Also, das heißt, da hatte man dann sozusagen die Engine schon fast fertig. Man musste sie nur noch niederschreiben.
Das heißt, da würfelt man dann auch?
Nein, es gibt einen Zufallsgenerator, der für einen würfelt, würfelt, simuliert.
Ohne, dass man das Würfel sieht in dem Spiel.
Man kann sie sich sogar anzeigen lassen. Also nicht als Würfel, aber als Wert, den man theoretisch gewürfelt hätte. Mit allen Rechnungen, die dann vorkommen. Verstehe.
Aber es gibt es das auch für das schwarze Auge. Dungeons & Dragons gab es schon in den 80ern Computerspiele dazu. Ja, wie gesagt, das schwarze Auge.
Aber kann man denn da auch dasselbe Maß an Kreativität entwickeln, wie man das jetzt in so einem Human-to-Human-Interaction-System macht?
Genanntenlos nicht. Die Geschichten sind immer sehr gradlinig und vorgegeben. Und selbst wenn uns mit irgendwie Zusatzseitenquests vorgegaukelt wäre, das wäre anders. Es ist letzten Endes, es zielt auf ein Ende hinaus oder vielleicht sogar auf zwei verschiedene alternativen Enden hinaus. Aber es bleibt dabei. Es ist komplett von der Kreativität bei dem Spieleentwickler und nicht bei denen, die das spielen.
Das heißt, ihr seid jetzt nicht so große Freunde davon?
Oh doch, ich bin ein sehr großer Freund davon. Aber ich sehe das Ganze nur als, naja, wie soll ich sagen, Nebenbei-Beschäftigung neben dem echten Rollenspiel. Ich ziehe echtes Rollenspiel vor. Ich bin sogar ganz verrückter. Ich bin sogar Live-Rollenspieler. Das heißt, ab und zu mit lustigen Klamotten und Gummischwärtern draußen in der Natur. Das macht sehr viel Freude, sehr viel Spaß. Das ist leider ein bisschen kostenintensiver als Tischrollenspiel. Und da wird einem die Kreativität schon wieder ein bisschen abgenommen, indem man nämlich das Ganze dann darstellt und die anderen auch sieht, wie sie es darstellen.
Ja.
Dicke Menschen können leider keine Elfen spielen. Ist halt ein kreativer Bruch. Das funktioniert ganz schwer.
Und spitze Ohren braucht man natürlich auch.
Ja, aber die kann man kaufen. Genau so wie man Spock-Ohren für Trekkies kriegt, kriegt man natürlich Elfen-Ohren für...
Aber bleiben wir noch mal im Moment bei den Computern. Okay, es gibt Games, die sich direkt an den Systemen orientieren, wo man dann eben auch in der Art, wie man ein richtiges Pen- und Paper-Rollenspiel spielt, das dann eben auch auf dem Computer macht. Aber es hat natürlich die Einschränkung, dass man eben jetzt nicht diese unendliche Vielfalt an Initiativen entwickeln kann, weil nur das, was der Computer auch versteht oder anbietet, lässt sich natürlich dann auch wirklich machen. Aber gibt es ja nicht auch so etwas wie einfach nur Rollenspiel-unterstützendes Software, die sozusagen den Pen und den Paper aus dem Rollenspiel rausnimmt und durch irgendwie Mouse-Keyboard und Bildschirm ersetzt, wo man seine Landkarten pflegen kann, wo man seine Spielsysteme, seine Charakterwerte, Erfahrungspunkte usw. speichert? Also so was weiß ich, so ein interaktives Scoreboard. Gibt es so was?
Gibt es, aber ich habe noch nichts gefunden, was taugt. Also viele, was man zum Beispiel viel findet, sind so Charaktergeneratoren auf Excel-Tabellen basierend. Oder zum Beispiel, ich habe selber mal...
Was da wohl für Charakter dabei rauskommt.
Oder ich habe zum Beispiel mal an einem Charaktergenerator Veshadran mitgeholfen. Der sogar ganz gut war. Ja, der wurde aber eingestellt, weil der Verlag dann gesagt hat, da steht aber zu viel von den Regelwerken drin. Und dann gesagt hat, ist nicht.
man muss sich da sozusagen um die Zensierung bemühen.
Ja, und dann gibt es fürs iPhone, gibt es irgendwie Würfelsimulatoren. Und es gibt auch Sachen, die versuchen, so dieses Bookkeeping, was man beim Rollenspiel an Schaden und so was zu unterstützen. Aber meiner Erfahrung nach taugt das alles nichts. Auch die Karten irgendwie mit Campaign-Cartographer. Muss man sich dann richtig in dieses Programm einarbeiten. Und bis ich mich da eingearbeitet habe... Das ist so eine größere Software. Und bis ich mich da eingearbeitet habe und irgendwie schöne Teils zusammengeklickt habe, habe ich dreimal meine Karte gezeichnet.
Und woran liegt das? Muss das zwangsläufig so schlecht sein? Oder ist das nur eine Frage der Zeit, dass das irgendwann dann noch mal kommt?
Tatsächlich muss es nicht so schlecht sein. Aber die meisten Leute haben keine Lust, viel Geld dafür auszugeben. Also muss es preiswert gehalten werden. Und dann kann man da nur entsprechend qualifizierte Leute dafür kriegen. Und das Ganze ist eine Abwärtsspirale. Und was der Kunde letzten Endes für immer noch viel zu viel Geld kriegt, ist dann halt sehr einfaches Gewurstel. Ich selbst bin der Meinung, dass man mit jedem guten Architekten-Programm bessere Sachen hinkriegt. Aber es kostet auch.
Und ein Open-Source-Software habe ich bisher auch noch nicht ordentlich. Da habe ich immer mal Dinge ausprobiert, aber habe ich auch noch nichts Ordentliches. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob die Leute nie damit spielen. Der Laptop am Tisch wird zwar immer häufiger. Allein schon, weil es immer mehr Regelwerke als PDF gibt. Zum Nachschlagen, ja. Zum Nachschlagen oder dass man seinen Charakter irgendwie, damit man nicht die ganze Zeit drum radieren muss. Oder es gibt auch Systeme, wo ich ganz gerne irgendwie einen ordentlichen iPhone-Charakterbogen oder iPad-Charakterbogen oder irgendwie was hätte, weil das vorsieht, dass man ein Backup vom Charakter machen kann. Und dann hätte ich schon gerne, dass da irgendwie so alles draufsteht. Und ich sage so Backup und dann kann ich mit der neuen Version weiterspielen und gegebenenfalls halt das Backup zurück spielen.
Denkst du, dass da die Touch-Systeme so da nochmal einen Wandel herbeiführen können, den so die normalen Computer so nicht?
Das wäre natürlich super. Das wäre toll, wenn da was passieren könnte. Also wenn sie dieses iPad oder so dazu hinkriegen, dass das gut funktioniert. Dass das den Charakterbogen ersetzen kann. Vielleicht auch den Würfel und klar.
Dass jeder so sein eigenes iPad vor sich hat. Und dann hat man da sozusagen seine ganze... Also Charakterbogen haben wir so noch gar nicht erwähnt. Das ist das, wo draufsteht, was ich für Eigenschaften habe, beziehungsweise Erfahrungspunkte etc. akkumuliert habe etc.
Genau, das ist quasi die Notiz darüber, was meine Figur kann. Je weiter sie sich entwickelt hat. Und dergleichen, was sie besitzt.
Und wie viel Arbeit würde... Ist das so viel Arbeit, das zu pflegen? Muss man da nicht nur ein paar Zahlen eintragen?
Na klar, aber wenn man jede Woche wieder Zahlen einträgt, das über ein, zwei Jahre hinweg, dann bleibt nicht viel vom Bogen übrig.
Klingt ja jetzt nicht so...
Außerdem kann ein Kaffee drüber laufen. Okay, kann übers iPad auch, aber das will keiner. Passen sie vielleicht besser auf. Nein, im Ernst, ich hab, ich selbst, hab schon anderen Spielern Charakterbögen leider versaut, weil ich da irgendwas drüber ausgeschüttet hab. So bei der großen Freude am Tisch, plötzlich was umgeworfen, das kann dann schon mal passieren. Okay, das wär auch blöd fürs iPad, aber...
Also hier gibt's sozusagen Development Opportunity.
Also da wird auch, es gibt wohl auch Sachen, wo dran gearbeitet wird, aber Schwierigkeiten sind zum Beispiel, die sind dann so was wie, damit kann ich da nur D&D darstellen. Aber nicht Shadowrun. Also ich brauch...
Na gut, aber spielen nicht die meisten Leute eigentlich nur ein System?
Ja und nein. Also viele haben ein Haupt- oder Haussystem, aber nebenbei noch anderes. Was das Problem daran ist, wenn es nur D&D unterstützt ist, dass nur die D&D-Spieler unterstützt werden. Dass die Shadowrun- oder Eclipse-Face-Spieler eben nicht unterstützt werden können, weil ihre Welt ja ganz anders aussieht.
Aber muss man sich halt nochmal eine iPad ab runterladen.
Ja, na klar.
Aber es muss halt nochmal entwickelt werden und dann sollte so ein Charakterbogen auch erleichtern, dass da eventuell noch ein bisschen...
Aber sind denn diese Systeme, ich meine, die sind zwar anders, aber sind die jetzt wirklich so anders, dass sich das so schwer abbilden lässt?
Also ich denke, dass man gerade einen Charakterbogen universell gestalten kann. Dann erkennt nur jeder sein System nicht mehr so richtig wieder. Beziehungsweise dann müsste er das immer einstellen, wie sein System gerade das vorsieht. Was es aber schwieriger macht, ist, wenn man auf die Hintergrundwelt eingeben möchte, wenn man das Ganze dann sozusagen als Karte verwenden möchte. Weil da braucht es dann doch schon enorm viele unterschiedliche Finessen.
Aber selbst beim Charakterbogen, wenn ich ein neues System anfange, jeder Rollenspieler kennt es, die Suche nach dem optimalen Charakterbogen. Da kann man sehr, sehr viel Zeit mit Verschwenden im Internet nach einem tollen Charakterbogen für sein System zu suchen, der irgendwie besser ist als das Ding, was der Verlag mitliefert, der irgendwie bestimmte Fähigkeiten hervorhebt oder mir mehr Platz bietet, wenn ich eine Magie erspiele, da ich mehr Platz für meine Zaubersprüche habe. Aber es ist halt eher auf die Ansprüche, die ich selber habe, und zurechtschneidet. Oder halt wichtige Werte besser hervorhebt, bessere Platzausnutzung auf dem Papier und ähnlichem. Und das selbe Problem ist halt auch auf einem iPad oder einer PDF.
Ich gucke gerade mal im Upstore. Gibt da so Dice-Roller und so weiter für das eine oder andere. Gibt es aber jetzt so richtig... Tabletop-Games sind hier irgendwie so ein bisschen... Fällt hier gerade so das Stichwort.
Na, das sind ja die guten alten Wargames auf Fantasy-Basis beziehungsweise Science-Wiction.
Also Tabletop ist ja sozusagen mit Männchen, ne?
Ja, genau, mit Männchen, ganz vielen in der Armee und dann rauf auf den Gegner.
Aber sowas spielt jetzt so in Rollenspiel-Ausstattung keine Rolle oder benutzt man manchmal auch so Zeug um...
Es liegt schon ein bisschen nahe. Das heißt, wer gleichzeitig Tabletop-Spieler ist, hat natürlich Figuren, das macht alles viel leichter. Man kann die 20 Gegner, die Böse auf einen einstürmen, gegen den einen Helden gut darstellen und muss es nicht auf der Fantasie belassen. Aber viele Rollenspieler sehen das Ganze so ein bisschen als Gift, so als gegen die Fantasie. Ja, es gibt's, wird aber häufig nicht gemacht.
Also man kann sozusagen mehr Komplexität damit abbilden, im Sinne von, was man sich alles so merken kann, aber dann wird's eben auch gleich komplex.
Und dann wird's vor allem sehr taktisch und strategisch. Denn dann befindet man sich plötzlich wieder im Brettspielmodus oder im Wargame-Modus.
Dann ist es schon wieder so ein bisschen World of Warcraft sozusagen.
Ja, die Erzählung, also die Erzählung geht dann weit zurück und es kommt nicht mehr, ja, und ich renn rüber und springe und zieh meine Waffen während des Sprungs. Wenn ich mich abgerollt habe, ziele ich auf Gegner X. Sondern ist dann so, ja, ich zieh da mal meine Figur zwei Felder weit und oh, da bin ich ja jetzt im Sichtwinkel von dem. Und damit wird man dann aus diesem kompletten Erzählmodus wirklich rausgerissen in, ich spiele auf einmal wieder ein Brettspiel.
Und man kommt sehr schnell in das Oh, dann doch nicht. Also viele Spieler, die ihre Fantasie folgen, sind sehr kreativ und machen sehr viel. Aber wenn sie das Ganze dann plötzlich optisch vor sich demonstriert sehen, setzt das Oh dann doch nicht ein, weil sie plötzlich zweifeln. Und das ist natürlich dann auch immer sehr schade und spielzerrüttend, wenn man das alles aufgebaut hat und die dann sagen, ach, Prüster, dann nehme ich lieber die Beine in die Hand und bin weg.
Okay, kann ich ganz gut nachvollziehen. Aber es gibt halt sozusagen auch das eine und das andere. Also sozusagen diese Computer-Seite und Pen & Paper-Rollenspiel, steht nicht unmittelbar an?
Nee, gar nicht. Computer-Rollenspiel macht leider dem Pen & Paper-Rollenspiel ziemlich viel Morgs, also kaputt, weil die Spieler, die Computer-Rollenspiele sehr exzessiv spielen, tendieren dazu, Alleingänger zu sein und nicht mehr gruppenkompatibel zu bleiben. Das heißt, sie wollen das Spiel dominieren, die anderen Spieler dominieren, ihr Charakter muss ganz vorne, ganz wichtig, ganz oben drauf. Und natürlich brauchen sie die anderen Spieler plötzlich nicht mehr, weil es ja uninteressant ist, die quatschen einem ja ständig rein. Also tatsächlich ist es so ein bisschen desozialisierend. Das ist ein bisschen schade und wird auch von so einigen Rollenspielern immer wieder ein bisschen traurig beugt, dass diese Computer-Rollenspiel-Entwicklung so sehr am Heimrechner stattfinden kann eben.
Und das Ganze so ein bisschen multimedialer auszukleiden, so als Spielleiter wäre natürlich auch noch so eine... Ich meine, gut, das mit den Karten, das Beispiel hatten wir schon.
Es gibt immer mal wieder...... Ja, klar.
Gut gemacht.
Also ich baue mir Playlisten für meine Rollenspielrunden zusammen. Ja, wo ich dann sage, das ist so gute Musik. Ich habe früher auch ganz viel an Musik gekauft, speziell für Rollenspielrunden. Das bringt zu den Düsteren rein. Und dann baut man sich so seine Playlisten zusammen. Das, was noch fehlt, ist, dass man irgendwie...... na ja, ein ordentliches Soundboard hat, wo die Spieler nicht sofort sehen. Also man bräuchte... Also nicht sofort sehen, dass man jetzt irgendwie den Drama-Button drückt oder so, wenn man bestimmt einen Effekt einspielen will.
Natürlich setzte es ein und es hieß Mortal Kombat. Irgendwie dramatische Hintergrund-Kampfmusik aus dem XY-Kampfspiel wurde dann eingespielt, um zu zeigen, es gibt Kampf. Aber...
Ja, kann ich euch empfehlen hier, so mit den Remotes und so weiter, so ein bisschen... Da könnte man sicherlich so einiges machen, was weiß ich auch noch, so Lichtsteuerung. Ihr seid jetzt im Keller, das Verlies fällt zu, auf einmal geht es Licht aus, irgendwie rotes Licht, Nebelschwaden...
Nebelmaschine zu Hause, jetzt geht es los. Nein, aber wird sogar gemacht, ganz, ganz im Ernst.
Wird gemacht?
Ja, wird gemacht, ganz im Ernst. Also Musik ist das Häufigste, was gemacht wird. Manchmal wird dann Akustik dazu genommen, das heißt, was weiß ich, Flüsse, Vögel, Nebelstürme, was weiß ich, was da so kommen kann, Türen quietschen, wird auch gemacht, nicht mehr ganz so häufig wie die Musik. Und ich habe jetzt kürzlich davon gehört, dass ein Spielleiter seine Spiele sogar mit selbst aufgenommenen und gesampelten Traumvisionen per Kopfhörer bedacht hat, während er mit den anderen Spielern weitergespielt hat.
Oder ich hab auch schon, persönlich hab ich auch schon überlegt, dass man zum Beispiel mit Videoaufnahmen arbeiten könnte, um bestimmte Aufträge oder so was zu verteilen. Also, das kann man unterstützen, soweit wie man will, und das Equipment ausreicht und wie man da Geld investieren will.
In dem Podcast über Arcade Games kam ja unter anderem auch dieses Spiel Dragon's Lair. Das geht ja auch so ein bisschen in diese Richtung, dass man sozusagen so eine ausgekleidete Geschichte schon hat, die man dann sozusagen richtig ablaufen muss. Ja, ist natürlich dann auch sehr linear mit irgendwie das Richtige, im richtigen Moment tun etc. Aber dann hast du dann eben auch so eine ja, komikhafte Ausgestaltung dessen, was dann sozusagen passiert, hängt ja auch schon so ein bisschen irgendwie damit zusammen oder ist auch mit Drachen.
Ja, aber das ist eher so dieses Fantasy-Ding, was er, also Dragon's Lair ist eher so ein interaktiver Film, als dass es Rollenspiel ist.
Ja gut, aber so als Idee für sozusagen die Begleitung, dass man sich dann sozusagen, ich meine, es geht ja schon mal, wenn ich mir so was anschaue, wie, Gottchen, jetzt fällt mir gerade der Name nicht ein, wie heißt er? Machinima, ja, also wenn man sozusagen so sowas wie World of Warcraft oder ähnliche 3D-Games benutzt, um sozusagen Szenerien auch zu, da Regie zu führen, die Charaktere zu skripten und daraus ein Videomaterial zu machen, ja sozusagen auch eine interessante Stage, auf der man dann sozusagen da so sein Geschehen relativ schnell zusammenzaubern kann.
Das gab's ja auch. Ich hatte nicht... Also ich glaube, im Vampire-Bereich gab's da mal was und Ultima Online ist ja an sich sowas.
Also zunächst erstmal, ich denke, dass Video-Geschichten schon wieder der Aufwand-Nutzen-Faktor einfach unterliegt. Das heißt, man kommt damit dann nicht für seine Spieler ausreichend gut hin. Also man müsste dann ja eine Woche basteln, um dann einen Tag zu spielen. Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht gut. Es gibt Spielleiter, die leiten fast hauptsächlich auf Conventions. Die haben ein Setting, das machen sie immer wieder. Für die wäre das natürlich ideal. Aber ich denke, in der einfachen Haus- und Heimrunde ist das Ganze zu übertrieben, also zu viel Aufwand.
Vor allen Dingen, also als Spielleiter habe ich ja auch schon so immer mehrere Stunden, die man an sich mit Vorbereitung, also wenn man nicht gerade so den Geistesblitz hat und sich so die paar Stichpunkte macht, wenn man es ein bisschen besser vorbereiten will, eine Karte zeichnet und Musik zusammensucht, außerhalb der Spielrunde muss man ja nochmal Zeit aufwenden, um überhaupt diese Runde vorzubereiten. Wenn man dann regelmäßig spielt, hat man ja immer diesen Zusatzaufwand als Spielleiter plus die Spielzeit selber. Auch wenn man sich gerne beschäftigt, ich habe früher in der Schule viele Charaktere gebaut, die ich dann als NSCs verwendet habe, weil mir langweilig war im Unterricht, also als Nichtspielercharaktere. Ich habe mir dann Pläne gemalt, aber umso weniger Freizeit man. Hat, umso weniger Zeit bleibt, um das zu machen. Und wenn man dann noch einen Film drehen will, das ist dann so für fünf Minuten Effekt.
Irgendwann wird das einfach mal alles so einfach zu machen sein, dass das vielleicht auch noch ein Element ist, das mit reinkommt, dass das natürlich dann auch gleich wieder die Fantasie einschränkt. Das ist das klassische Problem, was natürlich auch jeder Film hat. Jedes verfilmte Buch legt auf einmal irgendetwas fest, was im Buch im Prinzip noch offen gelassen wurde. Das ist ja eigentlich immer so die Standardkritik an Verfilmungen. Das geht natürlich dann an der Stelle auch so. Ich frage mich nur gerade, ob das sozusagen auch so etwas wünschenswertes wäre, wenn der Aufwand sich im Rahmen hält oder wenn das zumindest für einen selbst ist, um einfach so die Stimmung sozusagen noch zu machen. Weil man stellt sich natürlich erst mal immer so den nackten weißen Kellerraum vor, wo man dann irgendwie bei 15 Grad im Tisch sitzt. Und dann muss man sich sozusagen in die Fantasiewelt rein denken. Aber wenn dann sozusagen eh schon alles so ein bisschen aufgearbeitet wird, dann kann man ja dann alle Register ziehen und keine Ahnung, euphaktorisch vielleicht noch arbeiten.
Ein bisschen Aufarbeitung und Gestaltung gibt es immer. Die Leute sitzen dann ja nicht in ihrem weißen Kellerraum. Wenn sie begeisterte Rollenspieler sind, dann ist dieser Kellerraum ein Rollenspieler-Kellerraum. Das heißt, über Regelwerke, Karten, die für die Welt wichtig sind, über Poster, die irgendwelche tollen Sachen darstellen, von was weiß ich, Drachen oder Cyber-Knarren über Zeugs. Das ist natürlich dann schon ein bisschen eingerichtet. Und dann hat es was von Hobbyraum. Na ja, wie man will. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Hobbyraum. Und dann hat es auch dieses Hobby-Flair. Dann setzen sie sich an den Tisch und bestreiten ihr Hobby. Und dann funktioniert das auch leichter. Das ist ja nicht, dass man das...
Wie ausgestaltet und optisch ist denn das, wenn ihr dann so Live-Rollenspiele macht?
Ganz doll. Das ist schon ziemlich wichtig. Das ist ziemlich wichtig. Da gibt es dann tatsächlich auch Banner, Fahnen, irgendwelche tollen, was weiß ich, Deko-Elemente, sage ich jetzt einfach mal, um das Ganze ein bisschen kurz zu halten.
Aber wie macht man das dann live mit, ich meine, da gibt es dann selbe Prinzip mit Spielleiter und so weiter. Der läuft dann so die ganze Zeit neben einem her wie so der Regisseur beim Film, oder was?
Nee, das ist ja Quatsch. Als Live-Rollenspieler habe ich ja noch mehr die Möglichkeit, meinen Charakter darzustellen, so zu haben, wie ich das möchte. Das heißt, ich brauche niemanden, der neben mir her läuft und sagt, ja, das geht, das geht nicht, weil das sehe ich ja selber. Wenn die Tür zu ist, ist sie zu und dann kriege ich sie nicht auf.
Na gut, aber du hast ja nicht die Kräfte eines Orks.
Ja, aber dann stelle ich doch auch keinen Ork da. Und selbst...
Also alle sind nur humanoid oder was?
Nein, natürlich nicht. Nein, in den meisten Live-Rollenspiel-Werken ist es so, dass die darstellbaren Rassen sehr leicht darstellbar sind. Das heißt, sehr nah am Menschen sind. Das heißt, der Ork ist nicht doppelt so stark wie ein Mensch. Das lässt sich nicht gut darstellen. Also ist er eben nur so stark wie ein Mensch oder vielleicht ein bisschen mehr. Vor allem sind sie grün laut und haben zwei große Zähne an den Mundwinkeln. Sie sind natürlich über ihre Primitivität zu erkennen. Das heißt, sie haben dann sehr einfache Rüstungen, sehr einfache Waffen und so was. Das natürlich alles gestaltet werden muss.
Wollen nicht alle sowieso den Elfen spielen?
Nö, gar nicht mal.
Wir spielen dann den Ork.
Oh, eine Menge Leute. Gerade die Leute, die Lust haben, heute geh ich da mal hin und mach da mal ein bisschen Tert, so wie die Leute, die gerne Kneipenschlägerei wollen. Also natürlich kommt niemand ernsthaft zu Schaden. Ja, nee, wichtig, es geht dort alles sicher und fair zu. Das heißt, es kommt niemand wirklich zu Schaden.
Ja, aber man kann doch da auch nicht würfeln irgendwie, oder?
Muss man doch auch nicht.
Nee, aber wie macht man das denn dann mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit?
Man holt also sein Schwert aus und dann? Die braucht man tatsächlich nicht mehr, denn ob ich den Gegner treffe oder nicht, liegt jetzt ganz bei mir.
Das heißt, da geht's eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr um so ein Regelwerk, sondern da geht's eigentlich nur noch darum, ganz konkret diese Fantasy-Welt einfach auszuleben. Und da haut man sich dann einfach gegenseitig irgendwie auf eine Oma.
So ein bisschen, ja. Auf eine Oma gar nicht. Das ist strikt untersagt. Aber es gibt schon Regelwerke. Die reglementieren aber eher Verhalten und Möglichkeiten, als dass sie vorgeben, wie etwas zu funktionieren hat.
Und Spieleiter gibt's dann nicht mehr?
Doch, auch, weil die ganze Geschichte muss organisiert werden. Dafür gibt's die Spieleiter. Oder Streitfragen müssen geklärt werden. Und an der Stelle tritt dann der Spieleiter in Kraft. Es ist weniger wichtig zu wissen, kann ich jetzt meinen Gegner treffen? Oder wie viel Schaden mache ich denn? Denn entweder weiß ich das oder eben gar nicht. Also entweder ich weiß, wie viel Schaden ich mache, oder ich mache keinen. Und ich treffe meinen Gegner oder ich tue es nicht. Also das braucht kein Spieleiter in dem Fall, der mir sagt, ob das jetzt klappt oder nicht klappt. Es braucht nur noch einen Spieleiter, der sagt, so, jetzt hier mal zehn Orks, die müssen jetzt mal da drüben angreifen. Und hier mal ein paar Rätsel aufstellen. Also was weiß ich, irgendwelche Teile, Schnipsel, Jagden, Zeug. Also so Kleinkram. Also er ist für die Organisation fast ausschließlich noch zuständig.
Ja, er organisiert halt die Geschichte selber und spezielle Events, die in der Geschichte auftreten, die er dann mit Spielern, die Nicht-Spieler-Charaktere darstellen, also Statisten, wenn man es so will, in Gang setzt, dass die irgendwas machen.
Genau, die gibt es natürlich auch. Und die sind ganz wichtig, die Nicht-Spieler-Charaktere. Meistens sind die Darsteller davon, also die Spieler davon, für einen Bruchteil der Kosten bei der Veranstaltung und haben, soweit ich das weiß, weil ich bin so was häufig, sehr viel mehr Spaß als die Spieler, weil die Quatsch machen können, was dem Spieler so ein bisschen nicht gestattet ist. Da er ja daran Interesse haben sollte, seinen Charakter möglichst authentisch darzustellen und das auch die ganze Zeit und die Nicht-Spieler-Charaktere treffen sich häufig irgendwo in Räumlichkeiten im Hintergrund, albern da rum, bis sie wieder gebraucht werden. Was natürlich nicht heißt, dass sie bloß einmal pro Tag gebraucht werden, sondern es geht dann da schon zack auf zack. Also so eine Convention geht üblicherweise von einem, das ist aber eher selten, der Fall über zwei bis zu sieben Tagen, bis zu einer ganzen Woche.
Also so eine Convention für Live-Action.
Genau. Das geht dann eine ganze Weile. Und das ist dann mit dort campieren oder in einer Burg wohnen oder so was. Wird angemietet, kommt den Spieler auch relativ teuer, wenn es eine Burg ist. Das heißt, da müssen dann die Spieler auch schon mal 100, 130 Euro berappen für so ein Wochenende. Aber ist halt dann wie Erlebnisurlaub. Also es rechnet sich tatsächlich für den Spieler.
Und wenn ich zum Beispiel Vampire Life spiele, dann dauert eine Runde an der Regel eine Nacht.
Aber dafür immer wieder. Also Vampire Life Rollenspiele sind natürlich kontinuierlich. Das heißt sowas wie verschütlich.
Vampire betritt sich jetzt auf dieses Mafi oder was?
Naja zum Beispiel. Aber es gibt ja vielleicht mitbekommen diese Vampire The Masquerade Bloodlines und Vampire The Masquerade Redemption. Das heißt diese beiden Computerspiele. Und die wurden von vielen Rollenspiel-ferneren Leuten sehr begeistert gespielt. Und natürlich gibt es dazu auch ein Pen & Paper-Rollenspiel. Und es wäre nicht Rollenspiel, wenn es dazu nicht auch irgendwie ein Lab gäbe. Also ein Live-Rollenspiel. Lab übrigens, Live-Action-Rollplaying. Und in dem Fall bei Vampire reden wir von Vampire Life. Die Leute hören nicht so gern, dass das ein Lab sei. Und dann wird dann da ein bisschen rumintrigiert und Spaß gehabt, wie es zu diesem Vampire-System eben gehört. Und das ist kontinuierlich, wöchentlich, zweiwöchentlich, was die halt gerne haben.
Manchmal geht es sozusagen darum, wer am meisten Jungfrauen gebissen hat, hat gewonnen.
Ja, oder wer die schöneren Gedichte hat, wer die mächtigeren Kräfte hat. Ach, was weiß ich, also halt einfach Spaß an der Charakterdarstellung.
Auch da gibt es wieder Spieleiter, die z.B. Also es sind halt Vampire, in der Regel Vampire in der heutigen Zeit. Deswegen kann man es sehr kostengünstig auch spielen. Man kann es im Sommer im Park spielen, dass man sich im Park trifft. Wenn es kälter wird, mietet man sich gegebenenfalls mit einem Hinterraum von einem Café oder so an. Und dann ist jeder Spieler mit wenigen Euro dabei. Kostüme braucht man oftmals nicht großartig, je nachdem, was halt der eigene Kleiderschrank schon hergibt.
Aber da ist man dann schon so ein bisschen, da sind das schon so eher für Leute, die auch in der Schule beim Karneval schon Spaß hatten, oder?
Nee, ich mag Karneval überhaupt nicht.
Ich kann sagen, komplett überhaupt nicht vergleichbar. Also wobei man sagen kann, dass natürlich das für Leute ist, die sich in Charakterdarstellungen, Theater und natürlich auch Kostüm-Geschichten sehr wohlfühlen, ist es natürlich besser. Wobei Vampire Life gerade, die Leute sehen ja normal aus. Diese Vampire, um die es da geht, haben ja das Ziel, menschlich zu erscheinen, also nicht aufzufallen. Also ist das Verkleiden ja schon wieder nicht mehr in erster Linie wichtig.
Wenn ich irgendwie in den Edleren Vampir spiele, tauche ich im Anzug auf. Wenn ich in Schläger spiele, habe ich halt Zellis in der Jeans, Lederjacke, Sonnenbrille in der Nacht und Fängel parat.
Ist super. Aber das ist halt auch Live-Rollenspiel. Tischrollenspiel macht das Ganze glücklicherweise einfacher. Da kann man nämlich alles machen, was man möchte. Und ist nicht von diesem fiesen, gemeinen Ding quasi behindert, das sich Realität nennt. Man kann plötzlich als Vampir dann halt eben fliegen, an Wänden hochlaufen oder sonst irgendwas. Oder halt in Fantasy-Settings auch als 200-Kilo-Mensch eine Elfen spielen. Wobei ein 200-Kilo-Mensch als Ork ist schon beeindruckend.
200-Kilo-Mensch als weibliche Elfe ist sicherlich auch beeindruckend.
Aus der Erfahrung kann ich sagen, nein. Aber tatsächlich nein, also so als Ork, wenn derjenige dann auch die Mittel und Wege hat, durchzusetzen, stärker zu sein als man selbst, weil man einfach viel mehr Masse hat und den anderen schieben kann, dann ist das schon in Ordnung. Dann kommt das auch gut an.
Wow, also das muss ich mir, glaube ich, mal anschauen. Das Treiben, das ist ein bisschen schwer vorzustellen. Aber ich sehe schon, auf jeden Fall scheinen die Rollenspielwelt definitiv Leute anzuziehen, die einfach auch einen hohen Bedarf und eine hohe Fähigkeit haben, einfach Fantasie zu entwickeln und daraus sozusagen auch für sich spielerisch etwas herauszuziehen. Was würdet ihr denn sagen, was so für euch eigentlich der eigentliche Gewinn ist, sich im Rollenspiel so fallen zu lassen?
Was gibt euch das?
Spaß mit Freunden und neue Ideen entwickeln. Also vor allen Dingen, weil ich auch mir Gedanken machen über Dinge, die ich sonst nie machen würde oder könnte. Sowas wie zum Beispiel den Bankraub würde ich nie in der Realität machen, aber es macht unwahrscheinlich viel Spaß, für ein Rollenspiel sich zu überlegen, wie würde ich denn so eine Bank einbrechen.
Ah, verstehe. Also man kann sozusagen auch Dinge entwickeln, die man vielleicht in der richtigen Welt zu anwenden kann.
Das ist auch ein Problem, wenn man darüber in der S-Bahn zum Beispiel spricht und sich darüber unterhält, wo man dann seine Sturmgewehre herbekommt und den Sprengstoff. Und wie viele Leute man dann bei der, dass man das doch hätte sein lassen können, dass man den Typen da umbringt. Weil man redet aus der Ich-Perspektive und ja, und wie du da den Typen da um über den Haufen geschossen hast, das ging ja mal überhaupt nicht klar. Und die Leute um einen herum schauen dann schon einen etwas komisch an.
Ja, das Erlebnis für die ganze Familie.
Ja, könnte man nicht aus so einer Rollenspiel-Session auch ein prima Podcast machen?
Zu lang, haben wir ja schon festgestellt.
Man müsste das ganze Nebengeplauder wahrscheinlich rausschneiden, weil dann irgendwie drei Leute irgendwie was anderes.
Vielleicht reißt man sich ja dann auch anders am Riemen, wenn man jetzt sozusagen bewusst weiß, dass man wie in so einer Echtzeit-Filmgeschichte ist. Ach, Quark, findet nicht statt.
Aber tatsächlich, wenn wir jetzt das Nebengeplauder rausnehmen, oh, dann ist es plötzlich doch Podcast-Länge. Natürlich ist es sehr essentiell. Die Leute treffen sich ja nicht nur um zu spielen, sie treffen sich auch um Freunde zu treffen, sich zu unterhalten. Vielleicht nebenbei noch irgendwelchen Quark zu machen. Das ist halt schon was sehr, sehr Interaktives, also nicht nur auf Spielebene. Das heißt, wenn man sich als Rollenspieler trifft, hat man eine sehr gute Freizeitbeschäftigung, an die kein, was weiß ich, kein Kneipenbesuch rankommt. Also, was die Leute halt normalerweise tun, wenn ihnen langweilig ist und sie keinen Bock haben, Fernsehen zu gucken oder wenn sie Lust haben, sich mit Leuten zu treffen. Ich denke, dass Rollenspiele in der Hinsicht einfach viel mehr möglich macht. Das ist sozusagen wie ein gemeinsamer Video-Abend, nur dass das Video selbst gestaltet wird. Und das Ganze natürlich noch mehr einen angeht, also noch mehr an die Substanz gehen kann, noch mehr einen betrifft, einen einbezieht. Ich denke, es ist insofern... Ein sehr soziales Spiel eigentlich. Genau, etwas sehr Soziales, genau, das denke ich halt auch.
Ja, haben wir denn noch irgendwelche wichtigen Aspekte unerwähnt gelassen?
Wer mal wissen will, wie eine Spielrunde aussieht, sollte sich den Film Gamers anschauen.
Also, naja, gut, wer eine Parodie davon sehen möchte, das ist schon ein bisschen nicht ernst gemeint, aber es ist sehr interessant und sehr schön, das zu schauen.
Ist nicht ernst gemeint.
Die haben eine Mischung aus, sie stellen quasi da, wie sich ein paar Leute für eine Rollenspielrunde treffen und stellen die Spielszenen gleichzeitig dann immer als Live-Rollenspiel da. Aber es ist schon auf die... Also, als Rollenspieler kennt man das alles, was da drin passiert, aber es sind schon wirklich so die Spitzen rausgenommen. Also, die echten Spitzen.
Man hat sich ein bisschen zusammengesetzt und überlegt, was ist lustig am Rollenspiel? Wie kann man das noch lustiger machen? Dann möchte ich aber an der Stelle einen nicht selbstgemachten Film, also nicht privat veranstalten Film erwähnen, und zwar Astropia. Der gibt einen guten Einblick, wie Rollenspieler so ein bisschen funktionieren können. Also, dass das halt ganz normale Leute sein können und aber auch nicht. Also, es ist halt ein sehr durchwachsenes Klientel. Und dieser Astropia, der Film, der da rausgebracht wurde, ist ein sehr, sehr schöner Film und er bietet einen sehr guten Eindruck von dem, was da aus Istln möglich ist. Ja, genau. Übrigens auch in Deutschland zuerst gezeigt auf einer Rollenspiel-Convention.
Okay, naheliegend.
Aber sowas sieht man dann halt auf einer Rollenspiel-Convention.
Und auf welche Rollenspiel-Convention sollte man, also sollte man gehen oder ist das eigentlich erst so, wenn man den fünften Daden hat, dass man dann da aufkreuzt? Oder ist das auch schon zu empfehlen, um mal so ein bisschen Tuchfühlung aufzunehmen? Oder ist das gleich zu hart?
Na also, Tuchfühlung geht man, glaube ich, besser in einen Laden, in ein Geschäft, in den lokalen Rollenspiel-Laden und versucht da Leute kennenzulernen. Oder in der Regel kennt man vielleicht schon jemanden, der das macht und fragt immer, ob man nicht mal mitspielen kann.
Conventions, denke ich, sind schon ein großer Trubel, und was ganz Hartes. Das heißt, wenn man dahin geht, dann möchte man das auch erleben in seiner Größe. Das heißt, mal eben zum Gucken bieten sich die meisten Conventions nicht an, aber Conventions sind unwahrscheinlich toll, um Rollenspiele zu erleben, unterschiedlichster Art, möglichst viele, und die meisten Rollenspielsysteme, die man nicht kennt, aber gerne mal probieren möchte, anzutesten.
Aber das ist eigentlich schon so ein bisschen für Fortgeschrittene.
Ist tendenziell ein bisschen für Fortgeschrittene. Na ja, im Zweifel lieber zusammensetzen in den Spieleladen des Vertrauens, denn ganz oft ist es möglich, auch dort zu spielen. Viele bieten das an, richten das ein oder können zumindest sagen, wo man hingehen kann.
Man meint es ja, Supermax, Koffer sind jetzt nicht mehr so der Ort. Das heißt, eigentlich gibt es nur spezialisierte Läden.
Ja, Spiele-Läden. Es gibt die unterschiedlichsten Spiele-Läden. Jetzt nicht unbedingt Spiele-Max, aber es gibt in jeder größeren Stadt einen Laden, der sich auf Brett- und Gesellschaftsspiele spezialisiert hat. Da kann man anfragen. Und ansonsten die Läden, in denen man diese lustigen Zinnminiatoren sehen kann. Da kann man auch ganz gut weiterkommen.
Und gibt es da auch so Klassiker der Läden, die es schon irgendwie seit 100 Jahren gibt?
Na, das Funtainment hat eine ziemlich große Reihe. Da kann man mal gucken. Gibt es irgendein großes Funtainment? Gibt es in den größeren Städten auch in Berlin? Mir fallen jetzt die anderen Städte nicht ein.
Das ist schon eine richtige Kette, oder was?
Na, es ist ein Zusammenschluss mehrerer Läden. Da kann man tatsächlich hingehen und sich schlaumachen. Die haben auf jeden Fall rollenspieltechnisch Ausrüstung da und können einem weiterhelfen. Ansonsten fällt mir auf Anhieb nicht sein.
Traditionsläden, es gab mal das Beutel-End, was ins Morgenwelt aufgegangen ist in Berlin. Das war so ein Traditionsladen in Berlin zum Beispiel, den es wirklich seit Ewigkeiten gab.
Die meisten Traditionsläden in Berlin gibt es so nicht mehr oder haben sich verändert. Ich denke, das wird auch in vielen anderen Städten der Fall sein. Da hilft nur, die Augen offen zu halten oder das Internet zu bemühen und zu gucken. Rollenspiel laden, eigene Stadt und dann geht es los.
Und im Netz, was gibt es da so für Ressourcen? Es gibt doch sicherlich auch Plattformen und Foren.
Also in Deutschland das größte Forum dürfte vermutlich Blutschwerter sein.
Na, da kann ich wieder sprechen. Aber ja, Blutschwerter ist ein ganz großes Forum. Fundus Ludi ist auch noch ein ganz großes Rollenspiel.
Wie heißt das?
Portal Fundus Ludi.
Fundus Ludi.
Genau, ganz großes Rollenspielportal. Gucken wir mal gerade gucken. Spielen. Also Fundus ist natürlich klar, ist der Ort, wo alles abgelegt wird. Und Ludi ist Spielen. Wer kann mir sagen, wer war gut in Latein? Na Niels, ist vorbei.
Ich habe mein Abi drinnen gemacht.
Ich glaube, es ist halt du.
Ihr habt es auf jeden Fall gefunden.
rpg.net für den angelsächsischen Raum. Da gibt es das Ganze dann auf Englisch, auch ein riesengroßes Forum. Und dann die Seiten von den Verlagen. Also Ulysses-Spiele in Deutschland, Fanpro, Uhrenwerk-Verlag.
Uhrenwerk-Verlag, ja, genau. Ja, ich möchte an dieser Stelle natürlich auch dann Werbung in uns eigener Sache machen. Das heißt, Niels und mein im Fall. Und zwar für die sonntagshelden.de. Das sind die Rollenspieler oder ein paar der Rollenspieler Berlins. Wir sind echt viele. Und unser Ziel ist es, unser angesagtes Ziel ist es, die Berliner Rollenspieler und natürlich die Umgebung dazu zu bewegen, alle in einen Bereich zu kommen und sich dort zu organisieren, dort zu treffen, verabreden und ihre Spielrunden über dieses Portal Sonntagshelden zu bedenken.
Ihr spielt immer sonntags.
Ja, könnte man fast denken. Nein, wir spielen natürlich ganz oft Freitags, Samstags, Sonntags, wann wir Zeit haben.
Und warum dann Sonntagshelden?
Naja, kennst du Sonntagsfahrer? Das sind die Clowns auf der Straße, die sich daneben benehmen. Und wir sind die Sonntagshelden, alles klar?
Nein, liegende Assoziation bin ich aber jetzt gerade nicht drauf gekommen. sonntagshelden.de, ok, alles klar. Ja, schön.
Wobei wir uns natürlich gar nicht so sehr daneben benehmen, aber es ist eine schöne Parodie in eigener Sache.
Ja, ich denke, man muss sich da auch den Humor erhalten. Ich habe ja auch mal ein bisschen Rollenspiele gespielt. Das ist schon eine Weile her, aber ich muss zugeben, dass ich dann nicht lange verweilt bin.
Da kommen sie aus den Löchern. Ich habe mal gemacht, nur kurz, war mal dabei, habe es mal gesehen.
Ich habe meinen Finger mal reingehalten. Das war eigentlich auch ganz nett.
War nett.
Aber wir haben uns dann, glaube ich, irgendwann in einem klassischen Tod gestorben, dass wir dann irgendwann uns so obsessiv mit dem Regelwerk auseinandergesetzt haben, bis es dann irgendwann nichts anderes mehr gab als Regeln und dann war das dann irgendwie auch doof.
Ja, das kann ich natürlich vollkommen nachvollziehen. Was hast du denn gespielt, sag mal?
Das schwarze Auge lag auf dem Tisch.
Das schwarze Auge. Weißt du noch, was du da gemacht hast?
Wie meinst du das, was ich gemacht habe?
Na, zum einen, was war dein Charakter und worum ging es in der Geschichte?
Ich glaube, ich war immer Amazoner und am liebsten war ich eigentlich Spieleiter.
Ach so, selber sogar Spieleiter. Also ganz frecher.
Jetzt kommt alles raus. Bin mehr so der Moderator-Typ, ne?
Sieh an, sieh an.
Ja, aber was ich wirklich dabei gelernt habe, war Deutsch. Das fand ich eigentlich am interessantesten. Ja, ich hab, weil wir diese Regelwerke irgendwie gemacht haben und dabei irgendwie auch schon so die frühen Textverarbeitungssysteme bemüht haben, Visa-Wreit, Offensive 64 und so, lange ist es her. Ja, musste ich einfach formulieren lernen. Ich hab dabei wirklich extrem gut Deutsch gelernt.
Ich hab Englisch gelernt mit Rollenspielen, weil irgendwie die ganzen guten Regelwerke auf Englisch sind.
Ja, mir geht's genauso. Ich hab halt auch Englisch dadurch gelernt, deswegen spreche ich heute so einen komischen Bücherquatsch und insofern kann ich das gut nachvollziehen.
Ja, das sind auf jeden Fall angenehme Kollateralschäden, nicht? Also wenn man sich da einfach mal intensiv mit überhaupt irgendwas beschäftigt, dann fällt immer noch was ganz anderes bei ab.
Die Jungs von Schmidt Spiele damals haben auch ganz viel Mühe sich gegeben, also was Alte SA und so angeht, da ganz viel gutes Deutsch auch unterzubringen. Heutzutage ist es leider ein bisschen untergegangen. Also gerade was Übersetzungen aus dem Ausland angeht oder auch teilweise was deutsche Verlage angeht, da geht dann plötzlich deutsch-technisch ganz, ganz, ganz wenig nur noch. Also da könnte, also wenn ihr jetzt so ein Verlag zuhört, ne, gebt euch mal ein bisschen mehr Mühe, Jungs. Also es ist halt schon schrecklich, dass die Schüler in der Schule kein anständiges Deutsch mehr lernen. Im Rollenspiel dürften sie es dann wenigstens trotzdem noch.
Genau. Und hier haben wir uns jetzt auch bemüht, ordentlich zu sprechen, damit wir auch gut verstanden werden beim Podcast.
Na, hat's geklappt?
Ja, ich denke, das hat geklappt.
Wir danken.
Ja, das war eine schöne Reise hier durchs Rollen, durch die Rollenspiellandschaft. Und es gab ja auch schon so einige Sendungen hier, die sich so mit ähnlichen Welten auseinandergesetzt haben. Also abgesehen jetzt von den schon erwähnten Sendungen zur Brettspiele und den Arcade-Games gab es ja auch schon die Sendung zu den Computerspielen. Das hat jetzt so direkt nicht unbedingt was damit zu tun gehabt. Was mir jetzt gerade noch so einfiel, ich habe ja auch schon mal mit dem Gregor hier eine Sendung gemacht zu Perirodan. Das ist ja nun auch so ein extrem starkes Universum hier in Deutschland. Gibt es da eigentlich irgendwas?
Es gibt ein bisschen angelehnte Rollenspiele. Direkt gibt es dazu keins.
Weil das ist ja eigentlich auch eine extreme Welt, aber das trifft wahrscheinlich dann wieder denselben Tod wie bei Star Wars etc.
Dass das dann einfach so spezifisch ist.
Alle wollen Perirodan sein, aber dürfen nicht. Na ja gut, also denken wir uns lieber was eigenes aus. Danke nochmal und das war's. Ich sag Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.